Yippee!
Paragon!
Welcome back!
Master!
Lady!
Hello!
Welcome back to...
Eternal Darkness!
Yeah!
If it isn't the sauciest ghost out there!
Today I am all powerful.
I am backed by the power of Paragon.
Yay!
You guys like my...
My magic spell?
You guys like it?
I decided to be very colorful.
I picked some good colors.
I actually didn't pick a single mint color.
Oops.
Just pretend the green is mint, okay?
Just pretend the green is mint.
Hi Minto, hello!
What element are you?
Fire, cause I'm spicy.
How do you like my magic spell, Snake?
Cool.
You didn't even pick mint for your own colors.
It's fine.
It's giving PC-98 Marisa...
Good.
Love that.
Master Spark.
Did she have Master Spark back in PC-98?
Don't remember.
Anyway!
My Tia just got it.
It's still very hot.
Why is there a clown nose on your forehead?
I thought that maybe it looked a bit like a clown nose.
But I was hoping you guys would say Rudolph instead.
Nice Infinity Stones?
Thank you.
Oh, I'm sorry you can't hear the...
Sorry.
Anytime I play a game on like my PlayStation or whatever, you guys can't hear the...
The don't know sounds.
I'm so sorry.
Cause if I do this...
Then you can't hear it at all.
It's all complicated stuff, okay?
It's complicated stuff.
It's complicated OBS things.
But yeah, so welcome back.
Eternal Darkness Part 4.
I thought initially when I first made...
Especially since last stream, some people were like, oh yeah, I think you could finish this stream.
I think...
I'm going to go through just one chapter today.
I think we have three chapters.
I think I'm going to go through one chapter today.
I have some stuff I need to finish up tonight.
So if I go through one chapter...
That's why I kind of started at a strange time too.
I was like, I'm going to start at this time.
Especially because I was going to play on the weekend and start a couple hours earlier.
But then I had some stuff I had to take care of with my cat.
And...
I...
Oh.
I have five chapters?
I thought it was just three.
Wait.
Am I getting one guide?
You have a hundred.
I missed half the stream last time.
What has happened?
Oh gosh.
Wait, it's five.
There's four plus the girl left.
I thought it was three.
Wait.
Nah, I'm not going to play through the whole game again to get the final ending.
I'm so sorry.
We can watch it on YouTube or something.
Four plus one equals three.
Wait, Minto did four minus the girl instead of four.
No, I didn't do any four minus plus anything.
I read in chat.
Some people were like, oh, she has three chapters left.
So if anything, it's those people.
Why?
Minto stream right as I get off work this Monday.
Yippee!
I heard you like Paragon.
So we put Paragon in your spell so you can Paragon when you Paragon.
Wait, I'm so confused.
Never trust chat.
I'm so confused now.
Because I don't even remember what chapter we're on.
And I was leaving it up to you.
I was like, oh, you guys keep up so well.
You guys keep up so well.
I only have this many chapters left.
Okay.
Well, we'll get through what I get through today.
And...
We'll get through what I get through today.
I might just do one chapter today.
And then...
What I was saying is I might do one chapter today.
Um...
Uh...
And then...
Because I have some stuff I need to do.
And then once I'm back from my trip, I can endurance the rest of the game without any worry of time or limits or anything like that.
And feel a little bit more relaxed in terms of playing it.
And not like, oh, I got to get through this because I got to get through this.
I have a question.
I can make Doki play any one video game.
Charity thing.
Would you like it to be MGS?
MGS.
Would Doki like Metal Gear?
I don't know.
I've been sick for four days.
Can you scare my cold away?
I don't know if she would like it.
Make her play Winnie the Pooh?
There's a mint...
Para...
Paracombe.
What?
That's what I was worried about too.
I think she would maybe enjoy the story.
But it's like maybe not her type of game.
Turquoise soup for the minto.
You mean the mint?
Mint soup for the minto.
Make her play VR horror instead.
Oh god.
Why don't you play?
Have her play...
Have her play what you want.
Wait, why?
It doesn't have to be Metal Gear.
You asked me if you want to play Metal Gear, it's okay.
It was always...
Almost encouraged to pick something she wouldn't normally play.
Oh.
I sent her
a picture earlier this morning too.
I was like, when our fandoms collide.
I lied, and it was a picture that someone drew of Garfield as Snake.
I was like...
This is us.
What about...
Okay...
Hear me out.
This might be a little weird, but...
And it's not...
We don't even know when it's coming out, but what about Delta?
Because, you know, I could recommend MGS5 for the controls, because that's way more up her alley, but like...
Delta could be kind of...
You know, interesting.
For her to start with.
Depending.
But it's not out yet.
Do you need to make a...
Could you say, like, Delta?
Whenever it's coming out?
Nexi, ultimately, it's up to you.
It's up to you, baby girl.
Can you play VR Alien Isolation with her?
No!
I can't play Alien...
VR Alien Isol...
I can't play Alien Isolation as it is.
By itself.
You think I'm gonna play it in VR?
You think I'm gonna play it with her?
You know what she would do?
She would hide in the corner, and she would be like...
Mint!
Go do the thing!
Go do the thing, Mint!
And I'd be like...
We have to do this together, Noki!
And she'd be like...
Eternal darkness to our worlds without you.
Stop.
Okay.
And I would be too scared to do anything, too!
Paragon, paragon.
Paragon.
Okay.
Eternal darkness.
Where did we last leave off on?
Let me see.
Hold on.
We have been going kind of through time.
So the first thing that we did was we were Indiana Jones.
And that guy was kind of awesome.
We had a shotgun.
Love that thing.
We just kind of like obliterated everything.
It was so great.
If you loved us, you'd play Alien Isolation VR.
I don't even know.
I truly didn't even know that it was on VR.
I'll be honest.
And then afterwards, we played as a poor little guy.
He went to the church.
We went back in time.
Back to where that...
Oh my gosh.
The French...
We went to the French.
Thanks so much for the advice.
Good luck.
I'm sure whenever you pick, it will be great.
Tia!
I turned 21 today.
Can I get a Happy Birthday?
Oh!
Tia!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Tia!
I can't believe Mint wants Doki to start with Delta.
Okay.
I want Doki to suffer.
So maybe, you know what?
Have her play that Winnie the Pooh game.
I don't care.
Have her play a rage game.
Getting over it until she has to beat it.
For charity.
I don't know.
What was that?
Syphilis game or whatever?
Where you push the boulder up?
Have her play that one.
Oh, and so, yeah, we were...
We, oh, Alex Roivas.
We were this priest.
We're not Alex Roivas, sorry.
We were a priest and that guy was weak as hell.
But we, you know, managed.
We went back to the church.
There was that one guy who was trying to warn the captain of his demise.
But then this guy turned into a zombie.
There was him and we had to kill him.
You want her to start with Delta?
Awesome.
Use Ape Escape to fake her.
Yeah.
Alien Isolation is not in VR unless you mod it.
So it probably would be...
Since it's not optimized, quote unquote, for VR.
It probably would be super headache, motion sick inducing.
Now we are about to start a new...
A new area.
A new chapter.
Which people said this one is kind of...
Yes, the priest got his head blown up by the floating creature.
There is a creature...
There is a... Sorry, I just spat.
There is a creature that is guarding...
Something.
And it's...
We got to probably kill that thing.
Dum dum.
That's probably going to be the boss battle.
Of the final game.
Maybe.
Gonna raw dog Syphilis.
What?
Roberto is a low point but it's still fun.
Guy has terrible stats.
Okay, okay.
What?
It wasn't me.
It was the super child.
Okay.
We got our chapter.
Oh!
I didn't mean to do that.
I meant to do this.
It appears to be a page from the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
It is entitled the Forbidden City.
Should Alex read it?
Give me a second.
So yeah.
We learned...
Hold on.
We learned some crazy stuff last time as well.
Look at this.
We now have a...
Is that a pentagon?
What shape is that?
I need to go back to school.
Yes.
We have a pentagon.
And a square plus one.
Exactly.
Look.
We can make so many more spells.
Actually.
We have almost figured out all the spells.
So that's exciting.
Oh wait.
We haven't done summon trap or...
I just noticed...
My game is wide.
I think I messed up.
Wait.
Guys I think I messed up before.
I'm so sorry.
I'll shrink myself.
It wasn't so wide before.
Oops.
I forgot the settings.
My bad.
Um.
Okay.
Wide.
Wide screen.
Um.
But yeah.
We have like almost all the spells.
I don't remember what this one does.
But it's a...
We got...
I don't remember what this one does either.
I don't...
I never collected the stuff.
My bad.
I never collected the little codex.
Um.
This one summons a trapper.
And then...
Does this one summon the zombie?
Number 8 is summon zombie?
And then we control the zombie.
And then we have to kill our own zombie.
Kind of sucks.
We'll get...
I'll get used to it.
I'll remember.
I'll remember once we start getting into it.
Okay.
I don't know why I...
Let's use this chapter.
Let's go...
Conqueror?
Oh.
But what is not is far more interesting.
The Tome of Eternal Darkness mentions a Venetian artist and architect of the Renaissance.
Named Roberto Bianchi.
Bianchi?
Roaming abroad to find inspiration.
He was captured by a warlord.
Expanding his empire.
He forced Roberto to use his architectural and engineering skills.
To construct a monument to his greatness.
Oh.
To complete his task.
He must survey the site.
Okay.
1460.
Bianchi.
Roberto Mancini.
Was it... okay.
Survey the site quickly, dog.
And maybe you'll live long enough to see the sacrament's construction.
I'm the architect.
Right?
It's me.
You need me.
What?
Did you think we would trust you, Bianchi?
Bianchi.
Even though you are graced with the generosity of our liege.
You are still his prisoner.
As I said.
Finish your work quickly.
And maybe we'll drag you out of this hole.
I'm gonna become...
I'm gonna become the devil down here.
Roberto was the Picasso architect.
Stop.
Roberto must survey the ruins of this ancient temple.
The ruins he must survey can be found on the map.
Only when these areas have been inspected can the construction begin.
Do I have a map?
I have a torch?
From the get-go?
Yeah, baby.
What's the map?
The foundation for the monument has been constructed.
But it has suffered some damage.
Why?
How has it suffered damage already?
It's still being built.
The rest of the complex is unknown and Roberto must discover if construction can continue.
Maybe don't build your monument in the ground.
Novel idea.
Just kidding, we're going up.
Whoa!
So I have to make...
Who the hell are you?
Are you also stuck here?
Are you...
A frantic worker looking for answers to questions that can't be answered.
He hopes Roberto is there to save them and longs to see his family and friends once he escapes.
I'm also stuck here, man.
What's this?
This will lead us to the town.
Probably.
Okay, if you're a worker, get to work, man.
What are you doing?
This place isn't going to build itself.
Oh, my bad.
Why is there damage to this building?
Can you give my bro Luke some motivation to go to the gym?
He's not feeling it.
Luke!
Luke, you're going to feel so much better after you go to the gym.
I swear.
I promise you.
All you got to do is go and then once you go, you're just like, Oh, I'm so glad I went.
Can I set this guy on fire?
No, he just wants to see his friends and family.
You got to go, Luke.
You got to go.
That's an order.
I hear something squishy.
Why are you already here?
What the?
My torch!
Okay, good.
Finish him?
Oh, nope, he's dead.
Why are there zombies in your monument?
What just happened?
He's just...
Are you going to die already?
Roberto is so fine.
I love this guy.
I've known him for two...
Oh, no!
One of Roberto's fellow slaves lies dead!
His wounds seem to have attracted the attention of the beasts.
For they have been gnawed open.
Spilling his innards onto the dusty floor.
Thanks to the gifted!
Ghost exploring her natural habitat.
Oh, hello everyone.
What just happened?
What is this sound?
I see this.
Is that arrows?
Oh, crossbow!
Oh, we're going to get a crossbow!
Some day.
Eventually.
Should Roberto try to survey this area?
Wait, I'm scared.
Hold on, let me look around first.
I don't know what happens once I survey a place.
Can I set this on fire?
What is going on here?
This does not seem safe.
There's... there's just...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Hello?
An old safe lies discarded on the nearby ledge!
Uh, mine?
Thank you.
Yeah, Osha...
Osha needs to get in here stat.
This place is about to...
This place is about to crumble!
I want to talk to them.
That's what I'm trying to do.
I guess I can't.
I can only examine the area.
The structure around here shows signs of stress.
It is far from sound.
Perhaps with some reinforcement, it might be able to suit the requirements of the monument.
Oh, whoa!
What does that mean?
I'm Osha.
For real!
Huh?
Is that it?
I surveyed the area.
Now do your jobs, everybody.
Oh, wait!
Did it...
Were these...
These panels were here before, right?
Do I continue?
Climb down.
How many places are there?
This is our map.
Oh, okay, okay.
What does the X mean?
Huh?
Hmm.
Cooper, thanks for the gift!
I've been there.
Treasure.
I guess it's fine now.
I don't hear any crumbles.
So, let's go.
Oh!
Uh...
Hmm...
We have red guys on the right.
Blue guys on the left.
I don't think I missed the first one.
But I can...
Oh, oh!
Oh, no!
Oh, they're all gonna come to life as soon as I pull the lever!
There's so many guys in here!
There's so many in here!
I think I have to put on my sword.
I can't...
I can't use my torch.
Oh, it's dark, though.
It's a trap.
It feels like a trap, huh?
What's a...
Okay, what's my quick...
My quick spells again?
Sorry, I have to check.
Where is my spell book?
Oh, we don't have it yet!
I can't even do any spells!
Oh my gosh, I forgot I can't do spells.
Cinema!
Um...
Maybe I'll come back.
Okay, so we did this area.
There was...
Did I need to survey the other place?
Hold on.
Give me a second, guys.
I'm gonna go check stuff out real quick.
Hold on.
I missed my torch.
I'm guessing I don't need this yet.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, wait!
What's this?
Wait, is this where I came from?
Or is this where I came from?
Wait a second.
Uh...
There's a hidden...
Okay.
Just kidding.
So I don't need to survey this room.
It doesn't give me the option to.
What is... What room?
Huh?
I've only been to like two places!
How are these rooms already shown that I've gone in them?
Right?
Or maybe not.
I don't know.
Is there anything else in here that we missed?
It was a really tiny room.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, nope.
Okay.
Alright, I guess I gotta go pull the lever.
There's like nothing else to do.
Well, yeah.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
This place is the most confusing place.
I am confused.
And I'm only like two rooms in.
Climb up.
Let's go pull the lever.
I guess.
I'm scared.
I know it's gonna go wrong.
It's gonna go so wrong.
Maybe I'll save right here.
Wait.
Oh, it's not...
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
I gotta go back up and save.
Save and continue.
Alrighty.
Climb down.
Okie dokie.
Maybe I'll go for the guys with my torch first.
The lever is situated near the gate.
Should Roberto pull the lever?
Yeah, I guess so.
Oh, only one opened up.
Equip my sword!
Yeah, take that!
And that!
Finish him!
Oh, I wanna get my sanity low.
We want my sanity to be low, guys.
Low, low, low.
So I'll try not to finish the guys too much.
Oh, okay.
Pull the lever.
Sometimes I just wanna finish them so that they don't wake back up though, you know?
Oh, so the game is a little bit nice.
They give you the...
They don't do it all at once.
Okay.
And...
Ow!
Shit!
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Aren't you regenerative?
Regenerative?
Oh, the girls are fighting?
Oh!
His head!
No!
No, no, no!
Die!
Die, die!
Die, die, die, die!
Yeah!
And he'll die on the ground.
Like the sad little guy.
Ah!
You only have one arm.
So they're not gonna get back up, right?
Ah!
Oh, he's not getting back up.
Is he?
He's not gonna get back up, right?
Because they're basically dead.
This is our test.
This is our... this is to see.
Ah!
They get back up!
I have to finish them!
Hahaha!
Okay.
I learned my lesson.
You guys, we did a science experiment.
Just then.
Isn't the power of science so awesome?
We had a hypothesis.
Skellies will not get back up when you say finish them.
And then we did a test.
The scientific method.
Science rules.
So for the red zombies, I gotta finish them.
I think.
Oh!
Pull the lever!
And then these bozos...
I can just...
I can just take them down with my...
Are you gonna wake up?
Are you gonna get up?
Come here, normal guys.
Normal!
Guys!
I love you guys!
Yay!
Oh my gosh!
Look at them flailing on the ground!
Yeah!
Power of fire!
I love not being a caveman.
Konami sale on Steam right now.
Just picked up the entire Metal Gear series.
Oh, let's go!
I didn't know that there was a sale.
I saw it earlier too.
I appreciate Minto saying hypothesis not theory.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
This place is not safe.
There's just little rocks.
What am I picking up?
Oh!
The sacred crossbow bolts.
Why else would they be on this pedestal?
Not safe for work?
Yeah!
The work is not safe?
The place is not safe?
Nothing is safe.
This chapter irks me.
There's a statue that's easy to miss because it's hidden in the most unremarkable spot.
Granted, it's optional.
Only makes the final boss a little easier.
Oh!
You guys can backseat me for that if you want.
We got a crossbow!
Are you guys doing your jobs?
Huh?
This place?
Talk to him.
Come here, come here, come here.
The man babbles incoherently about worms devouring his countrymen.
And that Roberto will be next!
Oh my god.
The worms.
No wonder this place is not sound.
The guys are talking incoherently.
The man babbles about worms.
Everybody's talking about the worms!
Man, I feel left out.
I don't know anything about the worms.
Hahaha.
Won't someone tell me about the worms?
The worms!
Me too!
Worms!
Let's survey the area.
Dust and rock falls from the roof.
The worms got my family.
He's not lying.
No!
Dust and rock falls from the roof through a fault in the stone.
It is difficult for Roberto to assess how sturdy the place is.
But it needs a lot of reinforcement if it is to be built upon.
I guess that's it.
How many places am I surveying?
That's all that it needed?
Why don't we build actual pillars to hold up the ceiling?
You know, pillars are not just to look cool.
They have a purpose.
Four rooms?
Okay.
We've done two so far.
We're killing it.
Oh no.
Oh man!
This ladder leads down to the to the tome of eternal darkness!
Oh no!
Oh man!
We should have known!
Oh god.
It's going to get really loud, you guys.
Would you still love me if I were a worm devouring your country?
Yes!
Yearns to be claimed!
Okay, it's mine now.
That was weird.
Now we can cast spells.
Okay, now I can see what my quick spells are.
Okay, so...
Recover...
is Y.
Right is enchant.
item.
Purple.
I should probably have enchant item the other colors though, right?
Yeah, now he suddenly knows magic.
Do you think you'd pick up the tome of eternal darkness if you experienced that IRL?
Looks kinda cool to look at.
How do you get out otherwise?
How do you leave the room?
That doesn't seem like...
I think getting the tome of eternal darkness is your only option to leave.
You change the floors while looking at the map to see the survey rooms and how the rooms connect to this place.
Like... wait.
Hold on.
Gamecube controls I don't know so well.
How do I switch through the...
Y button is up a floor.
I guess we're at the very top.
Oh, Z.
Sorry, not Z, X.
Oh!
Those two!
And then there's a middle room at the bottom.
Oh, wait!
There's another room to be surveyed at the very bottom.
Thank you for the rate!
Oh, spectra!
Thank you for the rate, sorry.
It's white on white.
So I can't even read the name sometimes.
Thank you so much!
Thanks for the rate.
We're like part four of this...
of this wacky game.
If you don't know what's going on, neither do I.
But right now we have to go through a bunch of floors and survey them.
And we have two here, and then one in the very, very basement.
Amelia!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Let's go down.
Oh my god.
I got you.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I wish I could change my camera angle.
It's these things.
Don't worry, I'll save you.
Um...
Maybe I can switch to my crossbow.
I only...
Wait, no, I have...
You think that'll do it?
I killed something.
Ducky!
Thanks for the gifted!
Oh, reload?
It's okay, guy.
I got him.
I am God Gamer.
I don't think there's anything else.
Let's go.
You're safe.
The worker is surprised to see Roberto.
He confesses to cowardice as he stayed behind while others ventured further into the complex.
When the screams of the others echoed from the walls, he dared not move.
It's okay, little baby coward baby.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I heard something else.
Sorry.
Now I think we're good.
Oh my gosh, there was something there!
I didn't hear it, though.
Okay.
You're safe, probably.
You might wanna go upstairs.
Unless you wanna... He's probably so sick of the worm people.
La la la.
He's like, enough of these worm guys.
A collapsed roof and scaffolding prevents Roberto from proceeding further down this corridor.
Noooo!
It's just making it more difficult on us, isn't it?
Well, we can at least go up this way.
Oh!
This is not a good place.
Okay, maybe...
This is gas that's gonna kill me, isn't it?
Isn't this poison gas?
Is it killing me?
Wait, that guy... what is that in the bottom corner?
I didn't even move!
The phone hurting, guys.
It was him!
He did a little swipe motion and they noticed me!
Messed up!
Okay.
I don't know if that one zombie on the right or left...
Roberto's right.
Screen left.
I don't know if that thing can be burned with a torch.
I guess we'll try.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, it's this thing!
Oh my god, it's this thing.
I forgot.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Equip.
Finish him!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, and then this guy...
Ah!
Ah, shoot!
No, I'm trying to move!
No!
He's really draining me.
Open up!
Reload?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
For real?
Don't let him do it.
Yeah.
I wanna... I wanna maybe use this instead.
What's that in the middle?
Oh, I'm not close enough!
Oh.
Ah!
Shit!
Don't forget to enchant your weapon.
Oh, you're right!
What did he just summon?
Of course he didn't.
A little... I don't remember how to change...
I don't remember how to change targets.
I know that was a thing.
I only have three things left.
Mmm...
Okay, we're gonna have to, like, get really close for him.
Oh!
My sanity!
Not another one?
Oh no, it's time to start crying!
Oh, there's babies crying!
I don't want it to get too low, and then I can't even...
Do you think I can get him now?
Oh, shoot.
This guy takes... this guy packs heat.
Oh!
Oh my god, that's not what I meant to do.
I was reloading, and...
Uh, go back up, buddy.
We're not done here.
Okay?
I don't... it's sad to be on your high school.
What's he saying?
Make a test of me.
What's, um...
So, if he's green, I should do... I should do red, right?
I should, um, enchant... red, right?
He is green, right?
On my crossbow.
I can't hit him with the sword.
It sucks.
Very cool.
Alright.
Open up!
Do I have any left?
Oh, shit.
Open up!
Uh oh.
Guys?
I think that was my last one.
We're gonna enchant this one too.
And ironically, the best way to do Roberto's chapter is to just juke and run.
His weapons are bad and he is very slow.
Really?
Oh, should I just go then?
Um...
I was gonna... there we go.
I don't even know if we can enchant it.
Enjoy.
I feel like this is a sunk cost.
I need to at least kill this guy.
What the heck?
No!
How do I get this guy?
Didn't even connect.
I know, it sucks so bad.
This sucks so bad!
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
What is here?
It's not this way, is it?
Okay.
Oh yes, the thing in the middle!
Thank you.
A tattered scroll of paper sits atop the dives, collecting dust.
So...
The main zombie!
No, no.
Stay away, please.
They noticed me.
My sanity is so done.
My sanity is so bad right now.
Just run.
Just run, Roberto.
Run, Roberto.
I think we're in trouble.
So I go this way?
Whatever is in here is going to eat me alive.
Oh my god!
A worker's corpse lies amidst a pile of rubble.
The man's body has been pulverized by being thrown against the wall with such ferocity that it had collapsed.
So this thing is ruining our monument.
Wait, how am I...
Oh my gosh.
We need to enchant it.
Red, so I should do blue.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real.
Just kill him!
Just run, Roberto!
Roberto.
That's a wall.
Roberto, over here.
Roberto.
Guys, I think we're cooked.
I think we're so cooked.
Roberto!
Roberto, please, just move.
I'm just gonna let him kill me.
I'm just gonna go to the next...
Don't!
Just do a thing!
Try your best, Roberto!
He swings!
And he misses!
Okay, at least now...
We will have our crossbows.
If you must fight tough monsters, you'll want the Antarok Red...
Red Gormor spell.
The magic attack one.
Just watch Roberto's magic since he has so little.
Oh, this one.
This is...
Roberto!
Roberto, I'm trying to be...
I'm trying to be your...
Your hype man, but...
You make it difficult.
Oh, the shield spell.
Okay.
Yeah, I do have to remember, like, the kind of spells that I have here.
Alright, so we're loading.
Alright, I know we're a little...
I loaded, like, a little ways away.
That's okay, though.
Before the...
What's it called?
Room.
Before the...
The gas room, we shall...
Wait, where am I?
Oh, shoot!
I'm this far away?
Okay, never mind.
Damn, I thought I had saved sooner.
Okay, my bad.
My bad, guys.
In fact, let's just...
Where's... Oh, we don't have the...
We don't even have the tome yet!
Yikes.
Okay.
So, blue first.
Come here.
Yeah!
And... finish him.
The weakest chapter of the game.
Also, a reminder.
If you run out of sanity and monsters seize you, you take...
Yeah, I know.
That's why I'm, like, trying not to make my sanity so low.
I might have to, like...
I want to do the sanity effects, you know?
Because they're fun.
But I might have to refrain this chapter if he's...
If he's this weak.
If he's, like, so weak, you know?
If he's a weak, slow guy...
It's not your fault, Roberto.
I mean, it is.
It is your fault.
A little bit.
But, you know.
Oh my gosh.
The girls are fighting?
Yeah!
Oh!
His head!
No!
Their heads!
Can I get you?
There we go.
Finish him!
Get them to open their cloak, then run behind them and smack them.
Oh!
That works.
And...
Get our torch.
Easy peasy.
Pull the lever!
Crunk!
Oh!
That lever!
Crunk!
Alright.
Alright, wake up!
Wakey wakey!
Yay!
Flail!
Die on the ground!
I might just grab the thing in the middle, then.
The spell?
The codec in the middle?
Codex?
And then...
Um...
Ignore the guy.
Okay.
Let's go.
Climb up.
Yeah.
It's true horror game.
Survival horror game strats.
Don't kill everything that you see.
You don't need to kill everything that you see.
The real survival horror game strats.
Okay, nice.
I don't think I can torch him.
I think only normal zombies can get torched.
Survey this area!
Yes!
You are not Doomguy.
I am Roberto.
Guys, I'm just Roberto, okay?
Okay, so there's...
Oh, that's right.
We get the tome first.
Alright, work those legs, buddy!
Alright, open up!
Open up!
Alright.
Sniped.
Roberto is like a killer sniper, though.
Santo Pichi.
Wait, did I get it?
Roberto, I just complimented you and I think you missed...
Roberto!
Spell 9 instead of a crossbow.
Oh, like summon?
Spell 9 is summon our zombie and then we kill the zombie with the fire.
Mmmm...
What's the difference?
Hold on.
Question.
What if I summon him 3 star versus 5 star?
What's the difference?
Wait, I thought spell 9 was a zombie.
Is it spell 8 then?
How did I learn this?
It's so hard when I don't have the codex.
Spell 9 is a magic attack which you will need for a later chapter.
Oh my gosh.
It's actually seemingly overwhelming how much you can do in this game.
I know.
There's so much.
Yeah, chat is codex.
I truly would even be able to play this game without you guys.
Okay, I'm going to... maybe I will summon this guy then.
Alright, we're going to summon a little zombie.
Oh my
gosh.
Scared me.
Came up on me.
Yeah, this game truly hates Roberto.
Where is it?
No wonder I couldn't get it.
It's like way down there.
Okay.
We're fine, everybody.
Do not even fret.
You okay, man?
You okay?
I saved you.
He's so ungrateful.
Alright.
Let's save here.
Let's save.
This looks like almost something I can pick up.
Save and get the new.
Okay, cool.
Cannot save him from being a coward.
I know.
Alright, and let's take out this guy.
And let's get the thing in the middle.
Yeah.
Pick up.
And let's leave.
Bye-bye.
Now, this thing...
I don't know what to do with this guy.
Guys, I'm not sure.
I don't know what to do.
I'm so...
I don't know how to defeat this guy.
Just run?
But it's too narrow.
I can't get around him.
Blue crossbow to the face.
Yeah.
Let's try that.
Enchant.
I'm gonna do five on my crossbow.
Oh, this camera angle is diabolical.
Absolutely.
Oh, I see him.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Oh.
No, no, no.
No!
Roberto!
You must live!
What the?
Reload?
Please.
Roberto.
You did it though.
Maybe that...
Oh.
Where's my shield?
Okay.
Cast.
But this one is...
is same, right?
So, it's... I cast a red shield against red attacks, right?
There's a certain spot in the hallway where you can get around him.
It's by a ladder.
Also do a five point red shield and slide past him.
If he doesn't attack me, pass!
Oh my god.
Did it work?
Can you... Excuse me.
Go!
Roberto!
Roberto.
This is not the time to be out of stamina.
Roberto low.
Go, Roberto!
Open the door!
Oh my god.
Does that mean I can save?
Hell.
Hell yeah.
Splat.
Oh my gosh.
Roberto.
Just gonna reload.
And...
Um...
I'm just gonna equip my torch.
And... What's my stats?
Uh... Yeah!
I'll use this.
Nice.
So this...
Oh my gosh.
All my friends!
Ravaged corpses litter the room.
Their flesh has been devoured in places.
What?
In places!
And decomposition is already set in?
How long have these guys been dead for?
They've been devoured in...
Who knows where?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
So...
There's a door.
I see that.
Um...
Don't go in there.
Go in here.
What the?
You guys don't like my torch?
Is my torch not strong enough for you?
Oh...
Wait.
Are they blue?
Are these blue guys?
Are you blue?
Da ba dee da ba da...
Da ba dee...
Oh...
The tiny guy.
Go away, please.
I'm scared of the big guy.
Yeah.
Take him out.
Finish him.
Oh my gosh.
Actually do it, Roberto.
Run.
Now run.
Yeah.
Good job, Roberto!
You're killing it, man.
You're killing it.
Like literally.
You're actually... Wait.
What is it doing?
I don't like that.
Wait.
Oh!
These guys explode!
That's right!
This guy is just standing here.
He doesn't know what to do.
I forgot these ones explode.
It's all good.
Roberto is a pro.
If Roberto has zero fans, I am dead.
Oh, wait.
He's just...
Sorry.
I'm going to totally, absolutely save scum in this chapter.
I don't know.
This chapter freaks me out.
Where are we anyway?
Oh, we're so close to the...
So if I go...
down here?
No.
In here?
This is a room that needs to be surveyed?
Uh-oh.
The walls are bleeding.
Yes.
I hear the...
I hear the room being bad.
Oh, hello worker!
You guys are safe?
You are...
You are dealing with all those bogeys with just a torch, sword, and crossbow?
Whoa, mama, you're pretty good.
Is this guy okay?
These guys I can't talk to.
It's so sad.
They don't care about the worms.
You guys!
You have to know about the worms!
They're eating the countrymen!
They're eating...
They're eating your families, the worms!
Roberto tried to survey this area.
Yes.
Although crumbling in places and also have walls of dripping blood, the structure of this area could be braced to provide enough of a foundation for the monument.
What the?
Oh my god!
Is that my sanity?
Or are they actually trying to kill... No, my sanity is high.
The worms!
No, I shouldn't... I shouldn't kill them.
I shouldn't kill them!
Probably.
The worms!
Yeah, I was so shocked that they were fine.
But they weren't.
They got wormed.
Let's check out... Oh, never mind.
This door is locked.
Alright then.
I am going to save because I don't want to deal with those guys again.
I don't want to go back in there.
I don't want to look at them or think about them.
I'm done with worms.
Oh, damn it!
Sorry.
It was so close.
Well, I'll reload here, I guess.
Is there another one?
Why...
The camera...
was fine before and now decides not to be fine.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Stones and rubble from the collapsed ceiling prevent any passage in that direction.
Have we been here?
Use reveal invisible here.
Forgot what color though.
At this door?
It's the end of the Pius Chapter.
Yes!
I thought so!
I recognized for some reason.
I recognized this spot.
Of all places.
This is where Pius was!
Yes!
The missable statue is in an alcove in the wall somewhere on this floor.
I remember right.
Just pay attention to the walls as you explore.
Oh my goodness!
Thank you guys!
And sorry if some people...
Or rather, if some people think this is like backseating, it's totally...
fine.
I'm not even...
Oh, I should probably learn the five star...
Or the five...
Yeah, point, right?
So, um...
Oh, what was it?
Hold on, let me check.
Uh...
Check...
Narakoth...
Red Gormor...
Uh...
What color?
What color should we do?
Purple?
Red?
Oh, I guess it doesn't matter.
Um, Narakoth...
Red Gormor...
And Parkon?
Parkon.
Oh, the purple one makes you invisible.
So now...
Spell list...
Cast...
I'm gonna...
If he hollers at him, go...
My mom said to pick the very best color and you are it.
No.
I'm the real one.
Oh...
I'm in the right spot, right?
Oh, turn around?
Why did you guys stop me?
Look for a little alcove.
This?
Green!
Maybe it was red.
I was right the first time.
I was right the first time!
Sad, man.
Why the alcove set into the wall.
I can see...
I can see why this little alcove would be suspicious.
Because even walking over here, I was just like, oh this is like brightly lit.
And has nothing here.
So I get it.
How are you supposed to know that?
But I also am like, that's kind of BS.
I walked around to get my magic back up.
Did we even continue?
Awesome.
I'm gonna go in with my...
Oh my gosh.
A small statuette of a sorcerer driven mad by an unseen force.
It is made from a lustrous sapphire.
You can either cast reveal invisible, or if you clear the next room and double back, it is automatically revealed.
Gosh, you guys know so much about this game.
Oops.
I love the jingles.
These jingles are pretty fun.
You know that because you need to reveal right in the next room.
I see those feet.
Wait a second.
Leave.
Oh, I can't leave.
Wait.
Shield.
For something.
Where's my shield?
Why is this camera angle?
I can't see anything.
I'm scared.
Oh my gosh.
There's a key.
Oh my god.
What is this?
No!
Leave me alone.
Okay.
It killed the other guys.
Oh my gosh.
I almost ran into that.
Don't run out of... Roberto, please.
Roberto, run.
My shield is even gone.
How do I want to defeat this guy?
Can I even defeat this guy?
Is this one?
Should I?
Oh yeah, that's right.
It's unknown.
Wait, I don't even know...
Oh wait, I can see what little characters it is.
What symbols.
The sigils.
It's...
Funky Wing.
And the cool S.
I think that's it.
Yeah, Funky Wing.
Where did it go?
This one?
Cool S.
Paragon, Paragon.
Yeah!
The higher tier takes too long to cast.
Oh, I see.
I see, I see.
So maybe I should just try...
So if I do this, will it reach him?
I don't even know.
Do I have to get really close to him?
Three is better than five because it's quicker.
Wow, Aiden!
Thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you so much!
I don't remember... Okay, let's try it.
That was close.
Casually wandering.
He's running out of breath.
Ouch!
Ouchie, ouch, ouch.
Alright.
Am I too close?
And I attack in blue!
How did you like that?
And then I will do it again!
Can I poison... Will this poison him?
If I do it in the purple?
I still got him though.
Keep running, Roberto!
Roberto?
Roberto, get your steps in.
Get your steps in, Roberto.
Look, yep, yep.
Spell nine is expensive.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
How did I...?
Roberto!
He did his big steps.
He stepped over the spell.
Should I be good now?
Maybe.
Ouch!
No!
You!
Okay, well he just did it, so maybe I can do it again.
And...
Keep it...
Wow!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Sorry, I have to like zoom in on my desk so that I can see your name because it's white.
Because YouTube is stupid as hell!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Oh my gosh.
Keep running, Roberto.
I know.
You're really out of breath.
It's okay.
Oh!
Ah, shoot!
Don't die on me, Roberto.
Don't die on me.
Hi guys, I'm playing Eternal Darkness.
This game is kind of whack.
If you're like, what's going on?
I also don't know what's going on.
We have this tome of Eternal Darkness.
And...
We go through time as different people.
Right now, we're Roberto and we suck.
We're a weak, weak guy.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
That was so close.
Poor Roberto is doing his best.
I know!
I don't dislike him.
I just wish he were...
different.
I knew that was going to happen.
That's why...
I did this.
Ah!
Roberto, no!
Roberto!
Oh, Roberto!
Ah!
I'm going to die!
Can I even heal?
Wait, what's my recover?
Oh, there it is.
Ah!
Gosh, Roberto!
Run!
We have to run to get our magic back up, you guys.
Oh, we're so cooked.
Oh, Roberto.
And I can't even leave this room.
Hayden, thank you so much for the time you've given.
Thank you.
I can't leave the room.
The door is...
trapped.
I'm pretty sure.
I can double...
I can double try, but I think I couldn't leave.
If you're too far away, we'll keep spamming ranged attacks.
Helps to be somewhat close to him.
But far enough to cast.
I don't know.
Okay.
Droivus is the same actor who plays Porkins in Star Wars.
And the government agent in Indiana Jones.
No way.
All right.
Which one was it?
This one.
This is why I saved right outside the room, maybe?
I think he'll kill the zombies.
I think.
I think they, like...
The darkness comes.
I think they have, like, a little argument in there.
And so it's...
you know...
But just in case, I'll have my... my torch.
But yeah, see?
When I go to the door, it doesn't say open door.
So I think I can...
I think maybe...
Oh my gosh.
Is he right there?
Run, run, run!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna try and do this again with the attack.
I think.
So I kind of like waited a little in there.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, I'm so dumb!
Don't mind me.
Okay.
He's still doing ranged attacks.
I guess he's... Oh my gosh.
You're so gross.
Leave me alone.
I think I'm too close to him.
Hold on.
Let me get a little further away.
There we go.
Run, Roberto!
Run!
This game is GameCube, actually.
I don't think it ever got released on anything else other than GameCube.
This is the strat!
Just walk!
Roberto, walk!
Roberto,
walk!
Okay.
You tired?
Oh, no.
We're still walking.
We're going in a circle.
Alright, Roberto.
Just keep on walking.
You can see our little magic is going up.
The moment you don't see him on screen, he will range attack.
Okay.
Well...
We're keeping him here.
Come on, buddy!
Come here, buddy!
Wait.
This is kind of awesome.
This is the strat.
Wait.
I'm going to get a little further from him.
There we go.
Oh, he got me, though.
He got me good.
No!
No, no, no!
Oh, okay.
Yeah!
Run!
Oh, yes.
Roberto is so calm, cool, collected.
He doesn't care at all.
What are you looking at, buddy?
He's like... He's not even paying attention to this thing.
He's looking at the walls.
He's doing anything else.
Roberto!
Pay attention!
That's fine.
Oh, hell yeah.
Okay.
Ouch.
He got me again.
Got him again.
Okay.
Gosh, you're a tough guy.
He's so tall.
He's so... Not tall.
Strong.
I mean, he is really tall, but he's really strong.
Walking the pet dog.
That's the strat.
Come here, boy.
Come on, boy.
Yeah, he's a good boy.
Oh, we need to get your toenails trimmed soon.
Yeah, we do.
Yeah, he's a good boy.
He's a good...
What is...
Creature.
Can you get him with a trap or...
Well, I don't...
No, actually.
I'm kind of invested in this strat right now.
Even though it's, like, the longest.
I'm coming for you.
Come on.
I'm invested.
Oh my gosh.
He seems so done with me, though.
He seems so tired.
Wait a second.
Because he's...
I have a question.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Because he's red, is he regaining life?
I just realized that.
I...
I'm not sure.
I'm gonna poison him.
Shoot.
Okay, Roberto.
Time to get a move on.
No.
Yes.
Maybe.
I know.
We have no idea.
We'll see.
Literally every possible answer.
I sure hope not.
Yeah.
Get poisoned.
Is my...
Can I do another one?
Red enemies don't technically regain health.
They regrow limbs.
Their total health pool remains the same.
This is why the shotgun...
I trust Red.
Thank you, Red.
He looks...
He looks way more tired, you guys.
I think we got this.
He's...
He's not even red anymore.
He's like cooked.
He's burnt.
He's burnt chicken.
Thank you for the super chats, by the way.
Thank you for helping.
I appreciate it.
This game is whack.
In a good way.
All right.
Wait.
Let's get to...
Like about here?
Here.
And...
I'm gonna poison you again.
Yeah.
I'm gonna...
Get poisoned.
Oh!
It only took 500 years.
But the beast has been defeated.
Finish him, Roberto!
You earned it!
Hey, you're pretty part gone.
Yay!
Good job, Roberto!
And we didn't waste any...
Um...
Any resources.
Any, like...
Arrows or anything.
It was a completely...
Risk-free...
Way of doing it.
Save?
I will.
I'm just getting my stuff.
I'm gonna heal first.
I'm gonna heal.
I'm gonna get my magic back up.
Good job, chat.
We did it.
We did it!
We did it, everybody!
Okay.
This should be good.
Oh.
Whoops.
Uh...
Save the game.
Nice.
Get your...
Get your riches.
There's a key placed upon the pedestal.
It glints in the room's soft light.
Roberto has acquired the first gem.
Forgotten corridor key!
But what is...
What is this... what is the green spell for?
Why does it have a green...
Also, what is this room for?
Why is it just full of lava?
Where are we?
Oh, we're in this room!
And then if I go down one...
Which is X...
Yes.
It's a spa?
Oh, this is the sauna room!
What the?
Oh my gosh!
Grandpa!
Oh no!
Don't be so weak, Alex.
Yeah, Alex.
Stop being a little baby.
I didn't bring up a weakling.
Oh my gosh!
I don't think that's Grandpa.
You kept all this from me.
You kept me alone.
You shared nothing with me.
Grandpa!
I could never give you the burden.
Grandpa's kind of an asshole.
I wanted you to grow up.
Grow up and leave me alone.
What?
I wanted you to grow up.
Grow up and leave me alone.
But we killed you in your own perilous.
...
This can't be happening!
Grandpa!
Grandpa, why are you such a jerk?!
So I'm guessing it goes to this one.
Do you think those guys are still in there?
Save?
I already did.
I mean, I can save right here.
Save scumming for real.
That's okay.
We're save scumming for real, but that's okay.
Oh, I have a key.
The Forgotten Corridor, apparently.
Nobody wants to go in here.
Where does it go, anyway?
It goes...
to where...
Wait, what's that room?
Hold on.
So we're here.
We're about to go into here, right?
Yes, we're about to go in here and then we can... Okay, okay, okay.
It's nice how much you love chat and thanks for always starting stream right on time so...
This can't be happening!
I wasn't that late today!
Wow, this room is so fancy!
Look at all the lions!
Okay.
Oh no!
I was gonna say, so far, so good.
That was a lie.
Do you think there's traps in this room?
Uh...
Ouch!
How did those guys get so far?
Uh...
Oh, I see the glow now.
I see it.
Hmm...
Interesting.
Here's the Nikita rocket launcher!
Oh, I see the glow now.
I was gonna say it!
Or rather, I thought it.
I wasn't gonna say it because I didn't want people to be like...
Mint...
Mint... You can't make everything a Metal Gear reference?
But come on!
This is literally a Metal Gear reference.
How do I get past the yellow?
What is yellow weak against?
Um, maybe I do a zombie.
Alright, zombie!
Do your thing!
Here he comes!
I'm a red zombie!
Here I go!
I'm very slowly going.
Alright, here we go!
Oh!
I'm a red zombie!
Keep going, red zombie!
Maybe...
This was not the answer.
I...
was incorrect.
Ah, let's see...
Um...
I gotta walk around to get my...
energy back up.
Hmm...
My magic, I mean.
Anything can be a Metal Gear reference.
It's true!
Good experiment, boss.
Thank you.
My hypothesis was...
Red zombie is immune to the piss floor.
I was...
Is anybody truly immune to the piss floor?
Probably not.
Red shield and dash for it?
I mean, I did just save.
If I die, I die.
Dispel magic!
Do you think I can get rid of it?
But what gets rid of yellow?
Red?
What gets rid of yellow?
Hmm...
Purple?
That didn't work either.
Okay...
What's my magic at?
Look at your face.
I'm not saying there's something on my face.
Is there nothing to the left?
Over here?
Nope.
Won't even let me.
It's an invisible wall.
There's nothing over here either.
Another invisible wall.
Reveal...
Maybe if I reveal invisible, it will reveal the...
The way to turn it off!
Yellow is cut content.
There was supposed to be a fifth ancient god.
If you win game effects, use yellow.
Doesn't interact with anything.
Fly?
I don't have fly.
The unnamed fifth god is opposite to Manta Rock.
We just don't see them in the Pokmon wheel because you have to see in four dimensions to understand how the balance works.
If only there was a spell that protected you from attacks.
I guess I can cast it and run for it, man.
I'll try purple.
Let's go!
Oh, wait.
It's actually working.
Run, Roberto!
Roberto, run!
Roberto...
Yeah?
Oh, I remember this place too.
We fought a big guy here.
I remember, I remember.
Roberto...
Oh!
Roberto, don't fall.
Light those.
Okay, never mind.
The worms are speaking to me, you guys.
The worms...
Ah!
Hello.
The man babbles incoherently about worms devouring his countrymen.
And that Roberto will be next!
The worms!
The worms, the worms, the worms!
Is this guy gonna...
Wow.
Is this guy gonna turn on me too?
Such interesting decor.
This carving depicts a man's skeletal remains in the cruel embrace of a multitude of...
No way!
Worm-like creatures!
You know, in my artwork, they call it hentai.
Are these the things that killed the men in this room?
Oh my gosh.
Um...
A rope holds the bridge aloft, waiting to be lowered into position.
Alright, Roberto.
Do it.
Lower it, Roberto.
Roberto, cut the rope.
Roberto, do it.
Roberto, use your strength.
Whoa.
What's this?
Is this... This isn't where I came from.
Is it?
Oh, I guess it is.
It's a really, really big door.
Is this also the worms?
Oh, this is a different one!
Wow!
A hideous...
Bass relief?
Bass...
What does that mean?
Adorns the monolith.
Humans thrown into a nest of huge worms.
It is bass.
I can't get over that the worms are real.
The people have been sacrificed and justified the worms to fuel some unknown, unfathomable I can't get over the worms being real.
This is real.
I thought it was just in their heads.
Maybe I can cut it with the sword.
Roberto, you need to aim.
It worked!
Good job, Roberto.
If I have to kill that guy, I will.
Just letting you know.
The worms!
Oh my gosh.
Why did I not expect other...
Why did I not expect this to happen?
Oh my gosh.
The worms are real!
Bad worm.
Bad, bad.
Go back to the depths.
Bad, bad worm.
Go down.
Go down, worm.
Should Roberto try to survey this area?
Hold on.
I have to do something first.
What is this?
A lever is mounted on a nearby column.
Let's survey the area first.
Clearly, what's going to take down this monument are the worms that are burrowed deep beneath whatever is here and making the ground not very solid.
The dilapidated roof appears to be collapsing in several areas and will need a lot of reinforcement.
The workers will have to... will have a daunting task ahead of them.
Is that guy going to turn on me?
I think he's okay.
He still talks about the worms.
Yeah.
Okay, let's go pull this lever.
This game is about architecture, apparently.
Are we going down?
Oh no, we're leaving.
Okay, bye.
I guess, yeah, I would need that to open up to... yeah.
Okay, be careful with those worms, you know.
I'm surprised they didn't give them any weapons or anything.
To, like, deal with the worms.
Oh, oh, okay.
Yes, I remember.
Okay.
Spell list shield cast.
Level 5 magic.
Mantarok!
Run, Roberto!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
Oh my god, one shield left.
Wow, it really just lasts the amount of time.
What did the worm say after it devoured the countrymen?
Paragon meme.
Whew.
No worm about it.
Let's see.
Where do I need to go now?
What did that... imagine maybe opening that did something.
We still... oh wait, um, X.
We still have this floor.
But how do we get there?
Wait!
That one door, that...
Oh, oh, wait.
Maybe pulling the lever opened up this thing over here.
Um...
Uh...
Here!
Yes, it did!
Wait a... wait.
Wait a second.
No.
Just kidding.
Uh...
There is another room.
The other room.
Um...
Uh...
This...
This door.
Here!
Oh.
Please save.
I just did!
Did you forget to save?
No!
I literally just saved, you guys.
I literally just saved.
Just now.
Um...
I'm new.
Isn't that famous?
Maiden Mint.
The anime everyone's talking about?
Yeah.
I'm the famous anime.
Well, um...
Summon a zombie for the splatter.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Oh.
Why did I do that?
Get me out of here.
Summon zombie.
Paragon.
Hold on, Zombie.
I want to tell you.
I want to tell you one thing.
You are a sacrifice, but you are for a great good.
Okay?
Don't let anyone else tell you that you are not a great zombie.
No, my zombie is looking at me.
He's like, this is what's going to happen to me?
This is so sad!
Okay zombie, go for it!
I'm sorry!
It's so sad.
It was a real one, yeah.
Alright, I'm gonna actually... hold on, let me attach my torch.
What?
Oh no, it's that thing again.
Woah woah woah, what are you... you were summoning already?
What are you doing?
Did you even know his name?
Blue gas.
Blue gas is gonna bring my...
Oh gosh.
The trappers.
Take you down.
I think I should just run around this guy.
Bye!
Wait, but didn't he summon trappers?
Where are they?
Oh, there's one.
The walls are bleeding.
Just keep running, Roberto.
Who cares.
I have a feeling you're a partner.
Oh my gosh!
Who?
What?
I am the guardian of this temple.
You're a simp.
None shall enter except the chosen.
Oh my god, and his lady friend.
Ah!
You told me to speak.
You didn't even give me a chance.
You are the chosen.
Oh.
This place is only for the chosen one.
For many years I have tested those who came here and all have failed.
Oh wait, you are the chosen one.
You are unaffected by the power I wield.
And thus, must surely be the chosen.
I?
Once I was as you were.
Confused and without answers.
Now I'm dead.
Yet they came in time.
Okay.
Now my duty is complete.
Oh!
I can finally rest.
The walls will ooze human blood.
No wait, they already do that.
My sacrifice was not in vain.
Oh, Karim.
His girlfriend.
Right behind him.
That's a funny looking hat.
You gonna put that on, Roberto?
Oh.
Okay.
Uh...
Can I survey this area now?
Roberto can feel the acidic touch of the artifact's magic reaching toward him.
Using a shred of cloth from his ropes to shield his hands, he retrieves the hovering artifact.
We saw this thing before.
Did we not?
Everyone, don't forget to get your Minto Happy Now.
Pre-orders are available now from...
Oh, hi!
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Oh yes, you're right.
Happy pre-orders are available now.
But if you can't get it right now, that's okay.
Um...
Uh...
They'll be up for, I think, three weeks.
And it's made to order.
So...
Um...
Don't feel like they're gonna sell out immediately.
Wow, VTuber, I just pre-ordered my official Minto Phantom Happy Koda.
Yeah, nice!
Thank you!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Roberto has acquired the essence of...
Ullaoi.
Ullaoi!
Oh my gosh, the Ruby Effigy!
Cool.
Can I survey this room now?
The room appears to be an incredibly ancient shrine to the ancients, as noted in the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Could this be what Roberto's captor seeks to preserve with his monument?
Candy!
Welcome to Mambo Chef Taku!
I've surveyed all the rooms!
Roberto has completed his survey of the complex.
Now he can return to the surface and report his findings to his captor.
Oh.
Wait.
Seriously, I have to leave?
Oh, okay.
Um...
Okay.
Time to head all the way back, I guess.
Roberto, don't die.
That's right.
Okay, just power walk through it.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, now run.
Now run.
Yeah.
You're fine.
Just, like, walk through.
Yeah.
Just go.
Alright, then we came through here?
Wait, what's in here?
Oh, shhh.
Oh.
We didn't beat this guy either, did we?
Yippee, I free my mind.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, let's, uh...
Let's spell...
Um, shield...
Cast...
Good job, Roberto!
And climb up.
Oh, we didn't defeat this thing either, did we?
Oh!
Just keep running, Roberto!
There's never an end!
Just go!
Just go.
Okay.
It's time to go upstairs.
Upstairs.
The worms!
Oh, gosh.
You scared me.
Oh my gosh.
Uh, down.
Back down.
And through.
Uh, straight.
Yes, sir.
Climb up.
Everybody's still working?
Good job, everybody.
Nothing to see here.
Ignore my magical presence.
Keep going.
Run, Roberto!
Oh.
Oh, yes.
That was our first dead friend.
Wasn't it?
Wait.
What is this thing right here?
I feel like I should...
Should I do a reveal invisible and, like, something shows up?
Hmm.
Like, I feel like something should be here, right?
Tis a lump.
It's nothing?
Try it?
Because we have...
We have red and blue.
What if we did green?
Just gonna try it.
Oh.
Just kidding.
What if...
Paragon.
Record seven.
What if...
Paragon.
Liars.
Everyone is a liar.
Everyone's a liar.
Paragon.
Oh!
And what news do you bring?
Bring me, architect.
The...
The foundations are infested.
By worms!
The demons and devils.
And worms!
Many lives will be lost if you try to build there.
This is very shapely today.
You have done well to complete your goal, Bianchi.
The construction will continue as planned.
Oh, no.
But the demons.
You'd be insane to build this.
It's the sky.
Silence, dog.
What dwells beneath the Forbidden City...
It's shapely.
...is the very reason it was built.
Just you and me.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
My face is going to become so round.
I don't even know.
Let me educate you.
Guard!
Put this one with the others at the sacrifice.
What do you mean?
Sacrifice?
Oh, no, Roberto.
I am the scourge of God appointed to chastise you, since no one knows the remedy for your iniquity!
AHHHHH!
Um...
Oh my god!
NOOOOOO!
Does he die?
Oh god!
He's in the walls!
Oh my gosh!
Roberto's in the walls!
How did they do that?
Chapter complete!
That chapter wasn't even that long actually.
Maybe I should keep going.
Alex, are you okay?
Feeling a little woozy?
Oh my gosh.
Is that why we've been hearing...
WHAT?!
Should Alex try to survey the area?
No way!
An unseen force guides Alex's hand towards the painting.
Wait, compelling her to look behind it.
She reaches out and pulls back the painting and discovers a chapter page!
Should Alex retrieve the chapter page?
Yes.
Her familiarity overcomes her.
And as the chapter page comes to her fingers, so does the realization that Roberto's spirit is aiding her.
Oh!
I was like, I hear the...
Didn't we hear the rocks and stuff before?
Is that why?
Oh my gosh.
Roberto...
ROBERTO!
Uh oh.
We feed it flesh, but I fear it will not guard the relic too much longer.
There is no choice in the matter.
Uh oh.
It must remain and guard the artifact until the time of planetary alignment.
After that, the guardian may return to its lair.
Our master does not like failure.
It is imperative to keep the binding intact.
Do you think this guy even has a model or is he just like a big shadow mass with a face?
Did they even give him like a body?
Like a proper texture or anything?
He's just...
I can't see anything.
Uh...
A war to end all wars!
Whoa!
Also a fantastic chapter.
Also you can save the nurses, but it's extremely difficult.
I usually only manage to save one.
Nurses, you say?
Wow, that gives me a little bit of motivation to...
to...
play this one.
That last chapter wasn't even so bad.
Actually, I feel like that was one of the easiest chapters we've done.
Wow.
Alex is so cool.
It wasn't even so bad, right?
Like it was...
...
This one is much harder.
Oh no!
It's a fun chapter.
I don't know why people say it's bad.
Maybe because it's like...
A little...
What's the word?
How's my sanity?
Oh, it's low.
Um...
Uh...
Sluggish?
You can't fight back?
I guess so.
It is hard to fight back.
Maybe that's why people are like...
Not so fun.
Let's see if there's any strange happenings around with our sanity being so low.
This door is locked.
You already have the chapter page.
Yeah, I know.
I just want to see if there's any strange...
Any fun... What's it called?
Is that what we get?
Uh... Sanity thingies.
Oh, I just heard something squelchy.
What am I hearing?
And this guy is looking at us.
Yeah, as he does.
Anything I can hear?
Ew, it's so squelchy.
It's so squelchy!
Oh!
Can it drip on us?
No.
Yeah, just the ceiling bleeding as it does.
Oh, it's too dark.
That's right.
I need a torch.
Or something.
Okay.
Well, nothing interesting seems to be happening.
Our normal, normal bloody house.
As is.
Because last time we saw the guy...
Well, maybe the guy being hung was normal.
Maybe that was supposed to happen.
Because we had to go in there for the piano.
Oh, I mean this room.
Anything in here?
I know.
I can't tell if... There's a rat in my house!
Ah!
I can't tell if it's an actual AOL door closed or if it's just very, very similar.
What is that?
What's laughing at me?
It's like...
That was freaky.
A war to end all wars.
So, wait.
Is this one...
You guys said this one's difficult?
I don't know.
I feel like maybe I could do it.
How many chapters have we done?
I can't even remember.
That's me, guys.
I have a cold.
It's not really.
It's not straightforward.
This is chapter nine.
It's hard or not terrible.
To be honest, the Dancer's chapter is the hardest in the game.
The Dancer?
Have I gotten that one?
I think this one is long.
Huh?
Essence of Mantarok.
Look at this thing.
Mantarok's heart.
Talking about the method of execution, it's being hanged.
A guy being hung has different implications for the sanity effect you saw.
Oh.
I...
Yeah.
Oh.
Next character has a major handicap to sanity, but otherwise he's strong.
You can always start it.
Yeah, let's start it.
Let's start it at least.
Oh.
Yes, yes.
Read it now?
Yeah.
Come on, Alex, let's read our thing.
War, war, war, war, war.
Every day?
War has changed.
What?
Never changes.
His implication about the ancient's involvement with the war was hideous and so obvious.
Obvious?
With the horror of the Battle of the Somme scant miles away and the distant echoes of pounding artillery, a young journalist named Peter Jacob Peter?
Peter.
1916?
His grim task brought him to Oublier Cathedral.
Oublier?
Now transformed into a field hospital.
Wait.
Do we know this place?
Oh no.
Oublier?
I find no solace in the purpose behind all the senseless violence.
Are we actually in World War I?
Young men die at a rate unheard of in centuries of warfare.
Shelling, machine guns, and mustard gas rip, pierce, and burn to flesh.
Peter!
Oh my god, Peter.
Peter has truly seen war.
You see those eyes?
The hospitals here cannot cope with the torrent of wounded.
Oh my god.
Peter.
Peter needs some real therapy.
Peter does not look okay.
I think there might be a better way to carry that guy.
I'm just saying.
This poor dude is getting dragged.
He's like...
Whoa!
Oh my god!
What's this?
A soldier's letter lies on the table waiting to be sent home.
Soldier's letter!
Yes, we've been to this place.
We've been to this place.
Oh my gosh.
This is...
This is dramatic.
First letter from Private Reginald Jackson to his love Margaret.
Oh my gosh!
I was admitted to this hospital on Tuesday.
The damage caused to my legs was slight, but there is no way that I could ever walk normally again.
Oh my gosh, Peter.
I hate this place.
Every day I am reminded that I will never be able to do the things I love.
The hospital is a very strange place.
Converted from an old cathedral, there is an odd atmosphere around it.
Saddened before the words of the wounded calling out in the night.
There is no doubt, it is haunted.
And that ghost?
Me.
Yeah, this game actually only has like three or four locations.
Also, yay, World War One, blood for the blood god.
What I find most odd in this place is that you never see anyone leave during the day.
It's not right.
No goodbyes or farewells.
Just an empty bed when you wake.
What the?
A lucky penny?
Oh, I thought that was meat.
An old coin marked in a peculiar manner.
It has held sentimental value for someone.
Whoever holds the penny will undoubtedly receive good fortune.
It has blood on it.
The meat coin.
Flash pen.
He's a photographer?
This is a photographer's flash pen.
Used to hold combustible powders that when ignited create a large white flash.
This can be used to stun some enemies.
And we have the flash powder.
Very interesting.
Covered with blood stained sheets these poor souls have passed from this world.
For them, the suffering is over.
But for those around them, the ordeal continues.
The faint sound of moaning emanates from behind the linen veils.
Whoa!
What's going on in there?
Whispered utterances, frantic prayers to love words offered only by those who face their morality.
Spicy, yeah, indeed.
This guy's dead.
With a motherly voice, the nurse advises that Peter get some rest.
Get some...
Get some rest, Peter.
The soldier is rather distressed.
Perhaps he has lost a lot of friends to the trenches of the psalm.
He confides that the only stories are sad ones and that the only true heroes are in the mortuary.
I think this nurse likes me.
She knew me by name.
The soldier is rather distressed.
They all say the same thing.
Soldiers don't have original thoughts, I guess.
Are you gonna tell me to get some rest?
Wait, I've been here!
I've been down there before!
Let me in!
The guard quietly but strongly points out that the area is off limits to civilians.
I'm a soldier!
I'm no civilian!
I...
We can't even play!
We can't even play the organ!
The guard frowns and ushers Peter away from the organ.
He explains that it is one of the few antiques in the region that has so far survived the war.
And that, while he is alive, it will remain intact.
Oh yeah, we're journalists.
That's right.
I'm not a soldier.
Sorry.
What's this?
Sealed envelope!
Whaaaaat?
I'm gonna unseal it.
Soldier's orders!
An official note on Army Regulation Stationary.
The note reads Private Thompson, by order of Lieutenant Hargraves on behalf of HRH George V, you are to leave your post of duty and rally in the street outside Oblee Cathedral.
Further orders will be presented by the rallying point.
God save the King!
Boo!
Abruptly, the guard asks if Peter has clearance for the old tower, as it is a restricted area.
HRH, His Royal Highness.
Let's see...
Let's go downstairs, I guess.
This is... How is anybody supposed to sleep like this?
My goodness.
What is this?
A?
R?
The guard shifts about, obviously bored with his duty and awaiting a replacement or perhaps a call to honor.
Zone A.
Wow.
His Royal Highness King George V.
King of the United Great Britain and Ireland.
Emperor of India and defender of the faith.
With the war being so close, a curfew has been imposed.
Traveling outside the hospital is not a safe thing to do.
Since intruders will likely be shot on sight.
Peter decides to remain...
Do you hear what's going on out there, Peter?
I don't think you...
You wanna go out?
I was gonna say, there's a room...
over here.
Okay, the camera angle was different, so I didn't quite recognize it.
Nurse.
Oh, stack deeply on the landing crates of medical supplies await use.
Serrets of morphine, bandages, tourniquets, antiseptics, the list goes on and on.
Hello, nurse.
Can you talk to me?
I think I have a fever.
Nurse, I think I have a fever.
I don't think there's a...
Is there anybody alive here?
All there are are...
are just...
bodies.
Rows and rows of bodies.
I'm not gonna lie...
The...
The bombs sounds and effects get old pretty quickly.
Soldier's letter!
Second letter from Private Reginald Jackson to his love, Margaret.
I've been here for over a week now, and there is no word when I will be allowed to leave.
Strange things have happened.
At night, the sounds of the hospital change.
Echoes of voices that don't belong to anyone haunt the walls and corridors.
The restless ghosts, perhaps.
Or sounds of movement or whispers.
I have seen war firsthand, and the sounds at night in this hospital scare me more than I ever thought possible.
What is going on here at night?
Why do I feel so threatened?
My fears are worsened by the talk of the other young soldiers.
One said he had heard cries for help in the middle of the night.
Cries that were only answered by snarls of rage and not compassion.
I thought this was going to be like love letters.
You can't say that these are letters to his love of his life.
First ever woman in his life.
The most important person to him ever, and then it not be like a spicy letter to Margaret.
Not compassion.
Another said Lance Corporal Haskell has not been discharged, but has gone missing.
I stare at his empty bed with a sense of unholy dread gnawing at my heart.
Margaret's like, that's weird.
Weird, weird, weird.
Oh, we're in the bell tower.
What's this?
There's like something there.
You see it?
It's like a little lit up.
But I can't.
Punch it, Peter!
Punch it!
What is that?
Okay.
Let's go back down, Peter.
He's got a good fist.
Okay, where else can I go?
Hmm.
We can look at these, but we can't examine them.
Pew!
Nurse, I'm lost!
Nurse, I don't know where to go!
Uh-huh.
Is this my bed?
No, that's a dead man.
She told me to go rest, but like...
Where?
Is there someplace I haven't explored?
Oh, there's another door over here!
Maybe.
It looks...
Like perhaps there...
Oh.
No, I just didn't explore the corner of the room.
Huh?
Um...
Rest in the nurse's bed?
Maybe this one over here?
It's the only clean one.
Can I...
Sleep?
Please?
Can I go to sleep?
I got the orders.
Oh, you think it'll let me leave?
Maybe in here.
Wait, what was it?
What were the orders again?
Sorry, I forgot.
Soldier's orders.
Uh...
It tells us to go...
Oh, outside!
What?
Oh, okay.
We're going outside.
Maybe...
This guy.
Hey, man.
You go outside instead of me.
Oh, oops.
I don't wanna go out.
You go outside!
The guard unfolds the orders and begins to read them before exclaiming...
Bloody hell, lad!
We must be on the offensive!
Following the orders...
He takes leave of his post.
Okay, bye!
I was gonna go outside, but maybe...
You should go outside instead.
Oh!
A gun!
A revolver!
Should Peter pick up the revolver?
Yeah, baby!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Examine.
Thank you.
Oh.
Designed to muster patriotic feelings, these posters declare that the allies are fighting the good fight.
It's small comfort for the occupants of the room, who spent corpses lying on the cold cathedral floor.
Oh.
Uh, was there anything else in here?
Stacked like logs, Peter stands before the price of human war.
The bloodied corpses of young men who have made the ultimate sacrifice to defend their own countries and those of others.
Okay.
The music changed.
Uh oh!
Time to get a tow.
Oh my gosh!
It added someone!
Bianchi!
Bianchi's been added to the list!
Oh no!
This is looking pretty full in here.
Maybe we have one more on the right.
Oh my gosh!
I don't
want to finish him with the gun though.
I have nothing else to equip.
Can I unequip it?
Finish him!
Okay.
Nevermind.
Uh, the demons are here, everybody!
Be careful!
Oh!
Oh my
god!
Oh shoot!
I think I just shot the nurse.
Um.
Is she possessed now?
She doesn't notice me.
You're fine, right nurse?
Who's noticing me?
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
I have nothing!
I have two bullets!
Just run, Peter.
It's become a real survival horror game now.
Two bullets is not enough to kill anything that moves.
My magic!
Oh, so true!
I forgot I picked up the tome.
Um.
Let's just...
Run.
It is possible to save the nurse?
Yeah.
You have to shoot the bone thieves before they burrow in.
Yeah, I figured that was the case.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna, like, you know...
Hey, pay attention to me instead!
Um, I have nothing else.
Oh my god!
Spell nine was the attack, right?
Uh...
Wait, did that hurt her too?
Why are you getting hurt?
Ah!
Oh, I think she's dead.
Um...
Oh!
Did I just...
It's inside me!
Oh my gosh!
Oops.
Oh!
Peter has perished!
That's okay.
I don't think I saved before...
Before we...
Got the gun.
Or after we got the gun, rather.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh shit!
I didn't save at all!
Oops.
I got so into it.
I was like, Peter can do it.
Guys, do you remember when I didn't have a memory card?
Can you imagine?
I'll just skip through it.
The war to end all wars redefined how mankind looked at war and the value of human life.
I can't skip it?
Over 19,000 men lost their lives every day in the trenches of the Somme.
Some say uselessly.
Some invoke a higher cause.
I read accounts of the slaughter from many journalists who spent time in the trenches.
But I found the account of a certain Peter Jacob to be the most horrible of all.
His implication about the ancients' involvement with the war was hideous and so obvious.
Okay, nevermind.
With the horror of the battle of the Somme scant miles away and the distant echoes of pounding artillery, a young journalist named Peter Jacob researched his latest story from the front lines.
His grim task brought him to Oubli Cathedral, now transformed into a field hospital.
Oubli.
Why are all these cutscenes unskippable?
Peter, Peter, Peter.
Shelling.
Oh, we're gonna watch this again.
Come on.
You gotta be able to care...
Get another guy to help you.
...
Oh.
Oh, there he comes.
...
Okay, we picked up the soldier's letter.
It's okay, we can easily get back to where we were.
To where we were before.
...
No worries at all.
Peter Jacob.
...
There was one other letter.
We'll have to go to the...
...
Do you think if I open this...
Yeah, I think I have to.
Because then it's the soldier's order.
Okay, and now we go get the other letter.
...
Well, not the bell tower, but the other...
... the non-bell tower.
...
I'm, I don't know how I feel though, having...
Wait, not yet.
... having only a revolver and...
... having to rely more on magic than anything else.
I don't know if I liked it.
Because the magic takes so long to cast.
And those things are fast, the things that I'm fighting.
...
There's a rifle at the altar.
There is?
Oh.
Okay, I'll go check.
Does it only appear after... the bombing though?
Yeah, we'll pre-cast a shield.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll like...
But six shots!
But no ammo!
Yeah, Ocelot can say as much as he wants if he has...
unlimited ammo.
Yeah, six shots are all you need if you're Ocelot because he has unlimited ammo in his pockets!
Altar.
Rifle.
I'm examining.
Altar is cleared of all valuables, not only to prevent looting but also to afford space for medical supplies.
And even as an operating table should the need arise.
Aww.
Shows up later.
Okay.
Aww.
After the bombing.
Got it.
Hey buddy, you've been summoned!
Oh.
You've been summoned!
Bye bye!
These are the ones.
Oh my gosh, the... the bell one?
Is that a bell or is that like a prick?
Oh gosh, it's so... creepy.
Oh, it's... wait, it's maybe their helmet.
Ugh.
Don't forget to save this time.
Don't worry.
I know.
I'm gonna save after I pick it up.
Ahhh.
The music change is so freaky.
Red enchant, purple shield.
Seems to recall the bone thieves getting poisoned if you have a purple shield.
Two shots each.
Thanks, Rhett!
So let's enchant our gun.
Wait!
When do I get the tome?
On this door?
Oh, okay.
Here it is.
I was gonna say, it's... it's before I fight those guys.
Ok.
Gimme!
So dark... yeah, you could say it's a... an eternal darkness.
There we go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay.
Let's see, enchant.
Red.
To my revolver.
Shield.
Purple.
It's so loud.
Who are you?
Yeah!
Take that!
Oh my gosh.
Do you think I got it?
I don't think so.
I don't think I got it.
I only have one bullet left.
Wait!
Why isn't it working?
Run!
It's...
Let's see if the rifle is there.
It is!
A rifle lies on the altar.
Probably discarded by a fleeing guard.
I got a rifle.
Oh my god, everything is gone.
Why?
Why though?
Huh.
Why was it enchanted and the two shots didn't work?
Hmm.
So frustrating.
You guys want to know about the...
About the gun?
The Lee-Enfield Mark III bolt-action rifles are legends in their own time.
Completely reliable even under adverse conditions.
Over 3 million were produced in Britain, India, and Australia.
Wait, what about our revolver?
This Lebel Model 1892 revolver was introduced prior to World War I.
A double-action pistol was with a six-shot swing-out cylinder chambered for 8mm French service ammunition.
Bone thieves dodge ranged attacks while moving.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Get off of me!
How am I supposed to stop you from moving at me?
Oh my gosh.
I forgot about her.
Just run.
Just run, Peeta.
I know you're tired.
You can't stop though.
You're not allowed to stop running.
Oh.
Uh.
Don't shoot her.
Shoot.
Wait.
How do I?
Oh my gosh.
It keeps...
Damn.
Oh my gosh.
Dang it.
It keeps...
Getting on the wrong thing though.
I'm just gonna run.
I can't...
I can't remember how to change the...
What it focuses on.
That's my fault.
Get bone thieves...
Is this a sword?
Okay.
Now we're talking.
The two-edged sword?
We'll take it.
And...
Let's go.
Some ammunition.
Square?
Yeah, it's totally square.
What's this?
The room has fallen into disuse.
Basically only shoot when they are about to launch.
Okay.
The shelves, once full of books and scrolls, are now rife with dust, bearing nothing but trash and debris.
And rats.
There's so many rats in here.
Let's use our sword instead.
Might be easier.
Oh.
I can't remember what this is.
Let's enchant it.
My sanity is already so low.
Oh.
Red.
Sorry,
nurse.
I don't wanna do it, but...
Oh my gosh.
Ma'am!
Oh my god!
Finish him.
Damn, he does like multiple swings.
It's kind of awesome.
How's my health?
Okay.
Stab him good.
Oh yeah, baby.
I can go in here.
Oh.
I'm gonna use my sword.
Ah!
Kill him, dead!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even...
Oops.
I didn't even notice that guy.
Finish him!
Finish him?
Oh.
Boxes of medical supplies awaiting use and treatment.
Covered with bloody fingerprints, it is hard to tell whether they are actually used to save lives or just to relieve the suffering.
Oh!
This is new.
Those are bullets right there.
Oh, pick up.
There we go.
I see them.
Oh wow, there's actually a lot in here.
Actually, there's so much in here!
Oh my god!
Wait.
Okay, got that one.
Awesome!
Is that a tor- Oh, that's a rat.
I thought it was a torch!
I was so excited!
I am going to save.
Once again, I am saving.
Sorry, nurses.
My life is probably more important than- Oh!
Yay!
I did get a torch after all.
I love the torch.
I feel like these are going to move.
Actually, if my sanity gets too low...
If my sanity gets too low, what happens with them?
This room has been converted into a rudimentary morgue.
This room only?
I think this entire building has been turned into a morgue.
Bloodstained sheets cover the unfortunate souls who have passed beyond.
There's so many rats here.
If we don't die from the war, we're going to die from disease.
The altar stands wreathed in cold mist.
As Peter nears the stone, a sense of deep woe gnaws at his heart.
The cathedral is undoubtedly evil, and not the holy place he had thought it to be.
That is how it tended to happen.
Yeah.
There's nothing else in here, was there?
But we got...
A sword.
Which I'm actually...
The guys can't be killed by the flames, can they?
So we have to put on our sword again.
And I shall enchant it.
Sword.
Paragon.
And I'm going to heal.
Very good.
Come out, guys.
I know you were following me.
Where are you?
Is this...
Aww.
A guard lies dead at the foot of the steps.
Viciously assassinated by the creatures now infesting the cathedral.
He went quickly and without much of a struggle.
Okay.
I guess it's good that we...
Oh my god!
Oh my
gosh!
He's leaping again.
Leaping and jumping and...
Yeah!
Take him down, Peter!
Peter Owens!
Yeah!
Don't mind my sanity.
I'm fine.
I'm...
Fine.
Can I play the organ now?
Yippee!
Oh!
What's here, actually?
A piece of very old paper sits on the pipe organ.
Callously misplaced and forgotten.
Sheep music.
Gotta play.
The shelling is on.
The shelling has knocked out the cathedral's generator.
The organ cannot be used without a...
We saw that before.
The generator.
I thought the power was gonna go out in the chapter that we...
With the monk.
And that we were gonna have to turn it on.
But we turn it on here.
Interesting.
The organ cannot be used without a power...
A supply of power.
It can be properly...
It can probably be used if power is restored.
A.
B.
Y.
X.
Petty time.
I don't think there was a generator in the...
Oh!
It was a...
Wait.
No, there was something.
Maybe it wasn't the monk.
Which one was it?
It was a bellows.
There was...
There was a...
There was one, though.
I remember.
Oh!
Hello?
Did I just miss this completely before?
Or...
Um...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven?
Uh-oh.
Peter, we're not strong enough yet.
Seven?
I guess that makes sense.
There's like two other slots.
Yeah, we need a seven-point spell.
I am going to...
Sorry.
I know you guys are like, let your sanity get low.
But I also don't want to die, so...
Oh!
Are you okay?
Oh...
One of the cathedral's guards lies dead by his post.
His death was sudden and violent.
His broken limbs twisted at odd angles with the trickle of blood issuing from his mouth and ears.
I don't know if that's fine.
Could be.
It's not safe.
Wait, why not?
What's in here?
What's in here still that could get me?
If anything?
I don't know.
Hmm.
There's more bone thieves?
Wouldn't they have come up to...
I didn't
see that guy at all!
Oh my god!
Now can I save?
Oh...
Well, I guess the other guy from the bed, huh?
Oh, it's the war.
Oh, that scared me.
That scared me!
This is where we came from, right?
It's so dark.
Okay, here we can save.
Check out my bones.
My bones are fine.
Probably.
Santa, you know what you take when a bone thief...
breaks out is a massive?
Yeah!
It's alive.
Is there anyone else in here then?
Oh my gosh, that guy was just standing there.
Really scared me.
He really freaked me out.
Do you think this guy is down?
Do you think he's going to stand up?
Bone thief?
No, okay.
Okay.
Oh, let's open that thing too.
I forgot about this one over here.
Never mind.
Doesn't matter.
Oh my gosh.
Gosh, I can't get over that guy just standing there.
How much it scared me.
I heard whispers...
What is that?
What is...
There is a lot going on.
What is going on here?
Oh!
I'll pick it up!
Oh, the torch!
You guys are so right.
Please, I forgot about it.
Ah.
Yes, oh, oh, oh wait.
Wait, is this a...examined?
Guess we don't...we only care about some letters, but not all.
What is that?
Oh, it's a lamp!
Anybody in here?
You got little pieces of meat on the shelf?
Come in!
The desk kept meticulously clean.
Peter is surprised that it is not more chaotic for a frontline hospital.
After all, isn't this where the death certificates are written?
Maybe they don't even write them.
What if they don't even write them?
You know?
What if they're just like, yeah, you're dead.
I hear footsteps.
But...when I stop walking.
So this is the generator.
The workings of the pipe organ have remained mostly the same since installation.
Originally the bellows were...yeah, the bellows were driven manually.
Now they are steam-powered and the organ controlled electrically.
This might be one of the oldest restored pipe organs in the world.
It's a bomb, this place.
It's fancy.
How do I turn it on?
Fix it, Peter.
Fix it.
Peter, we need to play the organ.
You have to get it.
No, don't worry about it.
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
Nice.
Thanks for five bucks, the sniper.
Thank you.
I don't have...a crossbow.
Oh, but I have a gun!
How could I forget my gun?
Oh, wait.
I don't...I should...no.
Equip the gun, not the...the...
Forget
my gun!
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, the thrill of reloading in battle.
I've never felt anything like this before.
So it is one-shot.
Oh!
This is pretty spooky.
If I could see...
Oh!
That would be great.
There we go.
When he, like, kind of lowers his gun a little bit, I know...
Come on.
Oh, there's a lot of doors in here.
Okay.
Let's go to the right.
Oh!
What?
Don't mind the ceiling, okay, guys?
Perched on the wall beside the generator is an open-facing fuse box.
A fuse appears to be missing.
There's no sign of where it could be.
Oh my gosh.
This is like every indie horror game ever.
You have to find it.
You have to find a fuse for a thing?
Indie game...
Indie horror game developers love that.
Oh.
Whoa.
We never got to go in any of these places.
There's a whole little hole!
Wait.
I can summon a thing and go in there.
Old, rusty, crusty, but faithful for many years to coal-burning boiler...
Wait.
A coal-burning boiler provides heat and steam to the cathedral complex.
There's currently no pressure being diverted to the generator.
Should Peter turn the wheel?
Will it explode?
Um, hold on.
Wait a second.
I gotta...
Yes.
We're safe.
Oh, this is another door.
What the heck?
This place has turned into so much more of a maze than before.
I'm going to spell.
I'm going to summon a little trapper.
Here we go.
Oh.
He's right there.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, there's a thing here.
There's a person?
The body of a soldier.
A patient from the hospital lies slumped against the door.
Ah, so we wouldn't even be able to go in here because he's blocking the door.
It's the seven point.
Yeah.
Trying to hide from the horror, he had barricaded himself inside the room before succumbing to his wounds.
Oh.
Ooh.
All right, little guy.
You can leave.
Because I don't want to kill you.
This room is used to store coal for use in the steam boiler that powers the cathedral's generator.
Teleport him out?
What do you mean?
Small piles are all that's left, and with the almost endless war, a resupply is a long way off.
Oh.
Can I actually get him?
Wait, how do I use the power?
Oh, I have to target it first.
Got it.
Hold on.
I'm gonna heal a little bit.
I should probably just use like a sanity focus thing on him.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
We're gonna get that guy.
We're gonna take him.
We're gonna take him to another world.
Lalalala.
So, I press L to target him, and then I take him to a new world.
I take him to a whole new world.
I can show you par gone.
Ooh,
par gone.
Okay.
Okay, little guy.
Okay, here we go.
So then I...
Then he dies!
Poor thing.
I was attached to him.
Okay, it's so loud in here, my goodness.
Bye!
A circle of power sits atop a stack of crates in the middle of the room!
Circle of power...
So how many park guns do I add now?
Wait!
I made my head for only five!
And now you're telling me I have seven?
I have to redo my whole gig!
I have to redo my whole outfit!
Wait a second!
Just leave.
Just leave, Peter.
Sorry, I'm like trying to get back my magic.
So like enchant, I...
Oh, hold on.
Check.
I need...
Enter Buck and Magor More.
Enter Buck.
And Magor More.
And then park gun, park gun, park gun, park gun!
No way!
Park
gun!
I'll check.
Narrow Cough and Sun Talk.
Sun Talk.
Narrow Talk.
Wait.
Narrow Cough.
Park gun, park gun.
I can't believe!
Wait, so for each more that you get, you just keep adding park guns?
That's actually...
The runes you need are drawn on the scroll.
Yeah, they are.
But I am better with remembering the names.
Okay, this one is Narrow Cough and Red Goremore.
Narrow Cough.
And Red Goremore, I think it was.
Yeah.
Park gun, park gun.
As a member of the ancient esoteric magical order, I can confirm, we just add more park gun.
Oh.
What the?
Oh, that's just coal on the ground.
Well, now we can do that thing.
Dispel magic.
Shield?
Let's do shield as well.
Let's do all the powerful things that I'll use pretty quickly.
Bancorok and Sontok.
Bancorok.
And Sontok.
And then Paragon, Paragon, Paragon, Paragon.
If I try it with summon...
We're not gonna know what we summon though.
Not yet.
When in doubt, Paragon.
Are we gonna summon...
that creature?
Wait, what else will we summon?
Try it?
I'm scared.
I'm guessing...
Either the guy with the wings...
or...
the really big guy.
You're too Paragon to help.
We'll do it later.
I wanna see if I get a thing first, you know?
By thing, I mean like a...
Codex.
I would like a Codex.
Oh, okay.
I can't...
Oh, my sanity!
I can't... I can't leave.
Oh my god.
Freaked me out.
Oh, whoops.
Save and continue.
That was cool.
I like that one a lot actually.
Really like that one.
Oh, it's this one.
Again.
We've heard...
We heard this one earlier.
A soldier's body lies on the floor, far from the front line.
This poor man met his end.
His fate is far removed from his brothers in arms.
A victim of the cathedral, rather than by bullet or bayonet.
Oh my gosh.
Raiders!
Ah!
I didn't see who it was, but thank you!
Hello!
Miri Raids.
Hi, everybody.
We're playing a crazy game.
Oh my gosh.
If you're like, I don't know what's going on.
Just think Paragon.
Thanks for the ride!
Cask's full of maturing wine.
Do we need to do the one that's like...
Oh, these have wine in them.
Admit the rates of the cold air when the war is over.
If it is ever...
Or if it ever is, the wine will be a good vintage.
I guess.
TF2.
Thanks for the 5k.
We're going a little crazy.
So if you're like, wow.
This is...
What's happening with your screen?
It's like just that.
Okay.
So we redirected...
This rat looks so funny.
We redirected to that generator too.
I don't know if it did anything.
Going a little crazy.
Our sanity is the green meter.
It's quite low.
We just had our limbs cut off.
But it was our imagination.
It wasn't real.
It's just our imagination.
All right.
Let's open this thing.
Reveal.
Park.
What?
An odd collection of color lines decorate the wall.
Below the design steps appear to lead up to the wall going nowhere.
Oh, it's red.
I always forget which ones are the ones that are supposed to be the same color and which is the ones that are supposed to be the opposite color.
Red dispel.
I don't think it's dispel magic.
Is it?
Oh, maybe.
Oh, I didn't do this one.
Hold on.
Nethlek.
Red Gormor.
Red Gormor?
Where is it?
Oh.
Is it this one?
Yes.
It's the one that we don't have identity.
Oh.
Defied.
Right?
I think.
Red Gormor.
And then?
Question mark?
Probably.
The dispel.
Magic spell.
Yeah.
Yeah, I missed it.
It's okay, though.
It's all good.
Oh.
And then?
Let's see.
Let's do it.
It's either the reveal.
I feel like it's reveal invisible, but we'll try both.
We'll try both.
Red Gormor.
Bar God.
See?!
I knew it was reveal!
I knew it.
I called it.
Park on, park on.
There seems to be no way to open it.
Oh.
Well, great.
Calm down, Peter.
Peter.
Are there any more guys in here?
I'm scared.
Any more guys?
I'm hyping myself up.
The handle!
Let's take the one...
Remember we saw that glowing thing in the...
I saw a glowing thing in the...
That bell room.
It might be...
It was this way.
If I remember correctly.
Let's equip our...
sword real quick.
She's just...
I'm blocking her, but there's just a lady standing there.
I've got a fever.
And the only prescription is more Pargon.
Oh my god.
My sanity is completely gone.
Finish him!
Yeah, good job, Peter.
I am gonna restore some sanity.
I can do it.
A little sanity as a treat.
What's this?
Oh, I think it's just lighting.
Oh!
Alex.
So basically for anybody coming in and like, what's going on?
We're this girl reading about the stuff that we're playing.
Essentially.
Ah, sweet Alex.
And our grandpa's kind of weird.
I don't like it.
Many centuries I've waited for you.
Wait, what?
You are mine.
Don't disappoint me now.
What?
I've waited for you for such a long time, Alex.
Never!
I know what you are.
I've seen what happened.
Wait, grandpa is looking different a little bit.
Grandpa...
Oh my god!
You can try to fight me, but in the end you shall succumb to my desires.
Yeah, it's pious.
You don't even know your own destiny.
Get away from me.
Yeah, go away grandpa.
What if that's his name?
This isn't really happening!
What if his name is grandpa?
And you're just like, get away grandpa!
He's like, how do you know my name?
Anything in here?
It's not.
Alright.
Okay.
Just gotta go up here.
I was gonna say it's quiet in here.
But it's not quite quiet.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
You weren't in here...
What are you?
Oh my gosh, it's a blue thing.
Okay.
Actually, there's no handle here.
Just kidding.
I guess we don't...
Blue bone thief.
Oh my gosh, it's our first time seeing a blue bone thief.
Oh, I didn't do that.
That actually wasn't me.
It's Peter!
Peter, don't just do that!
Peter!
Aw, that poor...
nurse was just trying to hide.
If I were a handle...
Where would I be?
Let's check this...
Oh wait, we already went in the storage area.
That's where we got the gun.
Can we go outside?
Although scared enough to run, the journalist in Peter is determined to uncover the full story of the cathedral.
No matter what it entails.
To the bloody end, Peter decides to stay.
Peter, you're going to die!
Oh gosh, it's so dark in here.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh!
The poster changed!
Freaky!
Wait!
I'm fat?
Oh, your fate!
I didn't even use the right your if they were going to say you're fat.
Oh my goodness.
That got me good.
I'm glad we went in here.
Roasted by a low sanity poster.
Truly.
A handle.
I hear something.
Oh my gosh, it's like a lady screaming.
It's freaky.
Where have we not been to?
To find a handle.
Ah!
This can't be happening!
We tried to open the menu.
The penny is the key.
The penny.
Whoever holds the penny will undoubtedly receive good fortune.
The penny is the key.
No, I'm not done with the generator, but I don't know if I can do any more with it.
We can go downstairs and check.
Is there anything that I could insert the penny into?
Sanity recovering IRL.
I'm fine.
Maybe...
A small metallic object.
Is this the fuse box?
With the penny?
Wait, where was the fuse box?
Oh, we would need a fuse.
Right?
I would not have gotten that.
Oh my... what?
In a rush of inventiveness, Peter jams the lucky penny in place of the fuse.
I would not have...
Yawn!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
No.
I would...
What?
Peter jams the lucky penny in place of the fuse.
Amazingly, it works.
The fuse has been replaced.
On the wall beside the generator is an open-faced fuse box.
There's a lucky penny jammed in place.
A dangerous fix, but enough to bring power to the circuit.
Okay.
Huh?
Yeah, that's not a typical indie game type fuse.
For real.
Mute?
This can't be happening!
I love the meta sanity things.
Thank you.
It's making me hungry.
I should get a chicken.
A chicken sandwich with paragon cheese.
How do I get the fuse to turn on?
It says it's delivering...
Power, but how do I turn it on now?
Wait, here?
No.
Shame the system is locked behind copyright.
I think last time I played people said that the copyright for it is going to expire soon.
Or has already expired.
Like, recently.
Yeah, the patent expired.
Yeah.
For kids at home, don't do this.
It did say it was a dangerous fix.
The generator has a steady supply of steam and all the circuits appear to be intact.
Oh, here it is.
There is a lever to switch on the generator.
Okay, here we go.
Pull the lever, Peter.
Wait.
Whoa!
Oh, my game.
Whoa.
Let there be light!
Peep.
I didn't say peep.
Maybe I did say peep.
Did I say peep on accident?
And now this should be working?
The workings of the pipe?
Yeah.
Okay, let's go try our pipe organ.
I'm so sick of the bombing.
Sounds!
Oh, my God.
I'm glad we have good shoes.
Kind of ASMR.
I just heard something.
Is someone coming?
Over here?
Where is that?
Ah!
Oh, my gosh.
Where did you come from?
Oh, I should have...
Oh, no.
My sanity.
Come on, Peter.
Peter, we gotta make it.
Peter.
Peter!
Shit.
Ah!
Peter!
Oh.
Ah!
There's more of them.
Finish them.
Run away, Peter.
Peter, run away.
Peter, run away!
What the?
What's going on?
Oh.
What is this?
What is this sanity effect?
What's happening?
Oh.
I can't.
I can't do anything.
Like, no menus or anything.
What's this sanity effect?
Oh.
What is happening?
What if I go back downstairs?
Ah!
Okay, now we can do it.
Recover.
Cast.
A lot of sanity.
We went to another time.
Whoa!
It filled us.
It topped us off, baby.
Alright, now we can fight this guy.
Oh.
I'm ready to kill you.
Finish him?
Ah!
Shoot!
Oh, my health.
Run, Peter, run!
Oh, no.
My health.
It's actually so bad.
Maybe I should have healed that too.
Oh!
This camera angle.
Recover.
Cast.
Health.
Recover.
Cast.
Health.
Recover.
Cast.
Health.
Recover.
Cast.
Health.
Okay, are we good now?
Any other bone stealers about?
Maybe.
But we still have an organ to play.
A, B, Y, X!
G?
Play the organ?
Yes.
Oh!
A, B, Y, X!
B!
Y!
A!
I used deductive math.
The handle!
What are you staring at, Peter?
When you run over there, it freaks me out.
The tabernacle is almost empty.
Empty of all the things that should be there.
Such as holy water or other ritualistic items.
There's only a door handle lying on the lower shelf.
Take the door handle!
I'm gonna go back to the basement real quick.
Probably like, why are you going back to the basement?
Cause I wanna save the game.
Yeah, the paragon is strengthening my brain.
I never would have...
I never would have thought of the penny.
Oh, it's so bright in here now.
Please!
Please stop the...
The bombing sounds!
Please!
Oh, what's that?
Is that a hole in the ground?
What are you staring at, Peter?
Wake up.
I'm in the shun.
Boar.
Maybe the deeper we go, the less we hear it.
Ooh.
Should we be using PPPH before the spell?
Or before the paragon chat starts?
Hmm...
Umm...
Probably...
Before the paragon chat starts.
I think the paragon...
Is...
I think paragon is used for the chorus.
Ah!
What the?
Oh my god!
Ah!
They break out into little bone men!
Oh my gosh.
I'm hitting the...
Please!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is so bad.
I was hitting the sta...
I can't even get a...
Peter, this is bad.
Peter, this is really bad.
Oh my gosh.
I couldn't even move!
They just completely cornered me!
This is so messed up!
Peter!
Wow.
They... They got me good.
They really got me good.
Shieldman... I couldn't have done anything though!
I couldn't have.
They would've attacked me and then I couldn't do anything.
I didn't know that that was gonna happen.
Alright.
Seven point red shield.
That's exactly what I was gonna do.
That's exactly...
I was gonna do that.
I was gonna enchant my sword.
We're gonna go in.
We're gonna be ready.
Okay.
Spell.
Enchant item.
Cast.
Red.
Onto my sword.
That's so loud.
Hold on.
Turn it down just a little bit more.
Okay.
Alright.
And now shield.
Red shield.
Wait.
Wouldn't it be a green shield?
No.
You do opposite.
Gosh.
Wait.
Right?
Oh my god.
Turn around!
I need to take down the...
I need to take down the bone things before...
before I take down the zombies.
Oh this guy is...
Oh.
Never mind.
Are you getting in him?
Are you getting inside that guy?
Ah!
Yeah.
Take that!
Oh.
And I hit the stairs again.
Finish him!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Finish him!
I could have torch this guy, I guess.
Don't finish him, I guess.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I keep hitting the stairs.
Come up here.
Can you not?
Are you too big?
Are you too big for this?
Okay.
We got him.
Whoa!
Whoa to mix?
Enchanted shotguns too?
Oh if I like...
Otage?
Well that... Oh maybe.
It counts as like a mix.
Mmm.
I see.
Oh yeah.
I didn't even need the gun.
It's crazy.
I like the sword actually a whole lot.
Cause I don't have to think about reloading.
Hahaha.
Green shield protects from sanity drop.
Red protects health.
Blue protects magic loss.
I don't think I have to think about reloading.
Any normal enemy does this.
Purple?
Oh.
My bad.
Remember this area?
I hear... I can't tell if it's the ceiling or a guy that I'm hearing.
Is he a rat?
Even these guys are still here.
Okay.
Maybe I do need my gun.
Hahaha.
Thank you for playing Eternal Darkness!
It's been a fun ride!
It's also my birthday!
Deep woof!
Can I do your song in a deep way?
Happy birthday to you!
Woof!
Happy birthday dear Deep!
Happy birthday to you!
Woof!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the super chat!
I'm just gonna do purple and see if it'll poison him.
Deep woof!
Oh my god.
How's my sanity?
It's okay.
Let's go in.
Oh my god.
Please.
Attack him.
Instead of the small guys.
I have one bullet left.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
We took him out!
Easy, baby!
Equip the sword.
And finish him.
Finish him?
Hiyah!
What?
This is where we sacrificed that guy.
Sorry, monk.
Sorry, other monk.
I love having guns and swords.
And torches.
And shields.
I
meant to reload.
I shot that guy, but I didn't die.
Yeah, I love having everything that I need.
Maybe he did die.
I'm just too good at this game.
He fights much better than Roberto.
Seriously.
They were like, okay, we know.
We gave you a really hard time that...
Hello?
Finish him!
They were like, we gave you such a hard time.
We gave you such a hard time with Roberto.
We're gonna give you Peter who's just a total badass.
He's really good at his job.
What is this?
Oh, is this a soldier's letter?
A tattered letter lies forgotten on the chair.
Okay.
Sometimes the wording in this game...
Okay, just because something is like left in a place doesn't mean it's forgotten.
Like otherwise, everything in my room would be forgotten.
Because I put it somewhere.
That doesn't mean it's a forgotten letter.
It's just a letter placed on the trunk.
It's like...
It's a forgotten sock.
A long forgotten sock.
Wait, why are you both mentioning a sock?
Huh?
Forgotten laundry pile?
No!
I do my laundry.
Soldier's letter.
Let's check it out.
Number three.
Soldier's letter.
Forgotten s'mores supplies.
No!
Third letter from Private Reginald Jackson to his love Margaret.
It's been two weeks since Haskell went missing.
And I'm afraid to go to sleep.
More than once I saw shadows of people moving past my bed.
Peeking through the blinds to see a wounded soldier being taken from his bed.
Drugged and delirious in the dead of the night.
Never to be seen again.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna lose this war.
As Haskell was, perhaps as I will be.
What happened to them, I don't know.
A Metal Gear Rex figure abandoned for aeons.
It's actually a Metal Gear Rex box.
Because it's not constructed yet.
I'm afraid to ask what happened, for I know that I would surely be the next one to be taken into the darkness.
We're gonna lose this war because our men keep being kidnapped.
The shelf appears to be recessed into the wall.
Not quite as flushed as the others.
Almost as if it could slide inward.
Push it.
Yeah, in a second.
Let me save.
She does her laundry.
She just leaves it on the floor on $20 Amazon for...
What?
What are you talking about?
You've gone too far!
Just because my dresser was $20 from Amazon means I'm being frugal.
And it's not even on the floor.
It's a dresser!
Yeah, even Peter is like, what's wrong?
What are you talking about?
It works.
It's literally a dresser.
And also, I need to get a new one anyway because I'm out of space.
Because I didn't get one that's big enough.
What's wrong with my $20 dresser?
Did I save?
I think I did.
Push the shelf, Peter!
I'm just going to shoot this little creature right there.
Oh, that's a rat.
I almost shot you, rat.
I almost shot the rat?
Good.
Onwards.
You think he's going to...
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Creature.
Critter.
Grown-up dresser funds!
Oh, I can finish him.
Hold on.
Finish him.
It's a still grown-up dresser!
It looks fun.
It's just cheap.
Oh, his whole body...
A key lies upon this accursed shrine, glinting in the soft candlelight.
Oh, but this is not a forgotten key.
Binding hall key.
Hall?
Well...
I guess we'll...
If it's cheap and too small, that's a kid's dresser.
No!
I just have too many clothes!
I recently got like a bunch of pajamas that are like really big and fluffy, so they don't fit.
You know?
It's hard to fold them up.
Open the door.
Alrighty.
We came through this door.
We probably...
Can we go through this one?
Oh.
Uh...
Okay.
There's a door over here, yeah.
Okay, let's save again.
The meta is just save scumming.
It's forgotten large pajamas.
Oh.
Uh...
Use?
Can I use?
Use here?
Can use here!
Wait.
Huh?
Oh.
That was weird.
Yeah,
dummy.
Oh, my sanity.
My sanity.
Okay, let's get a little bit sanity back.
Let's get a little bit sanity back.
It's not...
They're not even that like...
Luckily, they're not even so like warm.
They're just like...
I don't know, they're just poofy.
Perfect.
Alright.
Oh, this is...
We're going deep, guys.
We're going downtown.
What's that?
Oh!
Ammunition!
I know we're only reaching spooky month, but have you heard about the Christmas Metal Gear Solid game?
I have heard about it!
We should play it this Christmas alone.
Oh my god!
So I'll have to miss your birthday.
No!
I'll be back in a couple of months.
I'll make sure to remember the basics of CQC.
Just like you taught me, boss!
Happy birthday!
Oh my gosh.
This music... is so fitting.
Stay loyal to the mission, yeah?
Remember the basics of CQC!
I believe in you!
Don't be like these guys, okay?
They suck.
Don't find any... any... bone snatchers now, you hear?
A scroll sits on a small...
Ooh!
Magical attack spell!
Whoa!
Did we know this one already?
Yeah!
The spell nine!
Oh!
My bad.
We knew this one.
But now I can actually do it with five Paragons and seven Paragons.
Check it out!
Let's see...
Antorbock!
Red Gormor.
Antorbock.
Paragon!
Oh!
No!
There we go.
Paragon!
Ha!
New spell.
Paragon!
Red Gormor.
Antorbock.
It even comments why it's there.
Wait, did it actually say?
I think I missed that part.
Alright.
Cool!
Please save before continuing.
Way ahead of you, buddy.
Uh-oh.
What's in there?
Um...
What should I enchant?
My sword?
My...
I guess we'll go see.
What's here?
The corridor is ended by an elaborate door decorated in a manner which is much different than the others within the cathedral.
Peter senses an unbearable evil beyond the door.
When he reaches it to open it, fear creeps into his gut and begins to eat at his soul.
Oh!
Is this the boss?
Is this the final boss?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait!
This is where his head exploded!
Oh my gosh!
This is where the monk's head exploded.
Oh!
Wait!
I'm not fighting this thing yet, am I?
No way!
What if I die?
That's like...
I mean...
No way.
I'm not fighting this thing yet, right?
What is this?
There's fly sounds.
Nasty.
Oh!
Pinschers!
Yeah...
Hello!
Wow!
Oh!
Hi!
Yeah!
Take him!
Get him, Peter!
What are you doing?
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Wait!
No!
Oh!
It's not...
I'm just going to go for it.
Did I do it?
I think I did it actually and it didn't do anything.
That's so funny.
I'm going to do my rifle...
Wait!
We have my rifle equipped.
We're going to enchant it.
Select an item.
Go,
go, get out of there!
Get out of there!
Oh my gosh, I'm moving, I'm moving, I'm moving, I'm moving.
Oh my gosh!
Holy cow.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, my sanity.
You missed the potion that fully restores your magicka eight times.
Oops.
Oh well.
Oh my gosh.
Get out of there!
I can't tell if that sound is it, like... deflecting or what?
Am I doing anything or what?
The stuck ricochet sound, right?
I think it's not doing anything.
I think it's reflecting.
Maybe I have to...
Maybe I have to enchant it with...
Oh my god!
Our head!
Peeta!
Maybe I have to do it with the stronger one.
The spell might work.
Or I...
Okay, isn't it Z for the magicka to target which one I want?
So maybe I...
But it takes so long.
I think that's the issue.
When it glows, it's vulnerable to spell nine.
But it takes so...
Spell nine takes so long!
To do!
Oh, whoops.
It's just a load game.
There we go.
This one?
Yeah.
Use only a three rune attack?
Okay.
Only need to use three... Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, I feel like anything else would take too long.
Alright, so then we'll do a...
Oh!
Calm down there, Peeta.
Calm down there, Peeta!
We'll do the...
Let's bring our sanity all the way up.
Even though he's gonna take it...
He's gonna... It's fine though.
Cast...
Sanitate.
The magic refill potion.
Where is it?
Where is it though?
In the hallway?
Let's go through here.
Oh, potion!
Potion.
Place where you found the custodian?
Huh?
Wait, what?
I don't remember that at all.
Oh?
Wait, I don't remember...
Wait.
The room across the way.
At the altar.
The one at the altar.
Wait, how do we get to the altar?
Here?
Huh?
Wait, I'm so confused.
Oh wait, I never...
It wouldn't let me into this room before.
And now it decides it's okay?
That's weird.
Wait.
Oh my life.
It didn't even let me...
That's so... What?
I tried to go in here before and it didn't even let me.
Oh, it was a sanity effect.
I didn't even know that could be a sanity effect.
That's crazy.
Where is it?
Where are you?
You're pointing at something.
Not what I need you to be pointing at, I think.
Or maybe...
Maybe...
Yes.
I'm not sure.
Is it across the way?
This game is crazy.
Yeah.
Oh, so in here.
I'm just so shocked.
Oh my gosh.
I was like, oh okay, I guess I can't go in.
Oh.
I just believed it.
Can I reload?
Can you reload?
Oh, there it is.
Minto.
Paragon.
See ya.
Later.
Paragon.
Thank you.
A milky blue bottle stands on the altar.
Oh, magical elixir.
Wow.
Is this his insides, you think?
A smile.
A small milky blue bottle is stoppered with a chipped cork.
This magical elixir will restore all of Peter's magical energy, and we can use it five times.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go.
Quit your...
Your heavy breathing.
All right.
Now we can go through here.
Okay.
Wait.
I went through the right way, right?
Am I going the right way?
Yes.
I didn't remember being able to see myself.
Okay.
And okay.
Let's do our enchantments first.
Wait.
Oh, no.
I wasn't...
Wait.
I don't think I should enchant myself.
I don't think I should enchant it, though.
I should only do this... the magical attack.
Let's quick spell this.
Let's do it to up.
Spell this.
Magical attack.
Cast.
Oh, no.
Assign.
Three star.
Red.
Up.
Okay.
So just press up.
Just press up.
And...
I...
It was ricocheting, though.
I really don't think it was doing anything.
I don't think it did any damage to enchant.
I think.
I don't think it was doing anything.
Okay.
Only when it's shining green.
Your gun was ricocheting.
Yeah.
I know.
That's what I was saying.
I wasn't...
I hadn't done any spells.
Yeah.
I didn't do any spells.
Because I...
Oh.
I did the one.
And I don't...
I would think I was too far away.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
The boss may summon adds of an enchanted sword is good.
But it'll...
It'll stop being enchanted maybe by the time he summons them right?
I guess we can still do it and just hold it.
Enchant item.
Cast.
Red.
On my sword.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I still have my shield.
I think I'm just gonna go in as is though.
And if I die, we'll reassess.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Yes.
I can't skip it.
Okay.
I have to press maybe Z, I think it is, for the spell magic.
What does the back of your skirt look like?
I have a reference on Twitter.
Under my schedule, you can see my reference thingy.
I think it's there, isn't it?
Sorry, I can't really think much right now because I'm on boss mode.
It's boss time, baby.
He's trapping me here.
Okay.
Why does Peter fight this thing, man?
Wait.
It didn't...
Did it do anything?
Oh, shoot.
What do you mean when she glows?
Oh, this part.
I see.
That was close.
That's good.
We get to run around and regain our...
magic.
I wish, though, I could see the floor better.
This camera angle is torture.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
All right.
Start glowing, lady.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm getting tired.
What is this?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Can you do something else?
We need to get here, maybe.
Whoa.
I'm too close?
We're breaking free.
If
you held out, we can do that now.
We're breaking free!
Is
she gonna... Oh no no, phase two!
Uh oh, I think she's summoning.
Actually...
Can I take these guys out with my...
with my... torch?
Instead...
She's glowing!
I don't wanna miss this opportunity!
Torch too strong, baby.
Welcome to membership.
Mint phantom.
Please, mint phantom.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch.
While you do that, I'm gonna...
I'm actually gonna recover...
my health.
You do your thing, I'll do my thing, okay?
Very cool.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah.
You do your summon, I do my summon.
It's awesome.
Am I still too close to her?
When are you gonna glow again?
Oh my gosh, that was close.
My sanity, though.
She's not glowing anymore.
Oh!
Oh no!
Ah, shoot!
Oh, there, now she's glowing.
Okay, okay, okay.
No!
Oh my god.
Ah, shoot.
I don't know if I'll have enough time to do this, but...
Ignore the summons?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, I'll ignore the summons.
Oh, I'm also gonna do my thing, too.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do a big sanity.
Come here, lady.
I mean...
Come...
Start glowing.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
Ah!
No!
Oh!
You made me miss my chance!
You made me miss my chance.
Potion time!
You know what?
That's a good idea.
I forgot about it, that I had it.
I know that attacks basically hits everything.
I know how it works.
Okay, wait.
Actually, I don't...
But the thing is, I don't remember how to change targets.
That's...
That's my issue.
Um...
I don't know how to change targets.
I don't...
Okay, I'll try to remember.
Oh, you're okay.
You don't need to?
Wait, what do you mean you don't need to?
But I'm focusing on one thing, so wouldn't it...
I was too slow though.
Okay, I was too slow.
Okay.
Oh, that's hard though because it attacks her last!
See previous Super Chat.
Sorry, I can't scroll up because I'm playing the game.
Okay, got lots of sanity.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, shoot!
Yeah!
Okay, that's the timing.
I'm running around.
I'm getting more magic.
What's my magic at?
What's my sanity at?
Sorry, I have to keep checking.
Recover.
Cast.
More sanity, please.
More magic, please.
Oh, yeah.
I guess I can do a shield, right?
Yeah, this makes more sense.
Cast.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
I'll do it next time.
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Even closer.
Are you okay, Peter?
Oh, my gosh, Peter.
Oh, we're right here.
Peter.
We're really close to her.
Oh, my gosh.
Peter.
Oh, my gosh, Peter.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, Peter.
Oh, Peter, I need you to run.
No, I don't want to die here.
I don't want to redo this whole thing.
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
How am I supposed to get her to glow?
Oh, like that.
I think I was too late.
Oh, I got her.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Is she summoning stuff?
Okay, no.
Oh, my hands are really sweaty.
First try.
Yippee.
Holy moly.
Okay, I...
I...
I know it's probably not needed, but...
Yippee.
Can I save?
That
is actually the hardest fight in the game?
No way.
I kind of feel like I cheesed it a little bit.
Examine.
But the guardian of Xelatoth vanquished.
And the stained glass that kept it hidden lying in pieces.
The essence of Chaturga is now liberated.
Oh, my gosh.
I need to see this.
Poor Paul.
Great job, Mitt.
See you next Eternal Darkness stream.
Thank you.
His magic beckons to Peter, calling...
Thanks so much for your help.
I appreciate it.
Calling to him.
He approaches cautiously.
Should Peter retrieve the essence of Chaturga?
Yes.
Peter reaches out for the artifact, but pulls away as he feels its corrosive magic close on his hand.
Wrapping his hands in a shred of cloth, he carefully lifts the artifact from its resting place.
Get Purgone.
Yeah.
Hahaha.
Here, I said I was only going to do one chapter.
And I did two.
Ha ha ha!
Sixty-nine years later!
And that was how I came by it.
I know it sounds crazy, but there you have it.
Nice!
The only proof I have is that statue.
Oh my gosh, he's alive!
It's a strange one.
He stayed alive!
I've seen one like it before.
You have?
Yes.
Very rare, though.
It's the asshole grandpa.
Very obscure.
I've had experts take a look at it.
Yeah.
And none of them know what it is.
And you do.
I'm somewhat of an expert on these things myself.
Oh.
An interest I developed a long time ago when I was a young man.
So that's why he's not in the world, in that...
Lord knows I have no interest in it.
He didn't die by the paragon.
I'm sure it's the cause of my sleeplessness.
I keep thinking about it.
As if...
It's calling out to me.
Golden.
Better drink, perhaps.
For the gift.
Live the rest of your life.
For an unusual objet d'art.
Objet d'art.
Live the rest of your life as little as you have left, Peter.
Wait, where does he hide it, though?
Aren't we supposed to go find it?
Objet d'art.
Alex, you good?
Having stopped reading, Alex discovers a small penny.
Taped to the back of Peter's chapter page!
How does...
We got the lucky penny, but...
How?!
You guys hear that?
Baby crying.
Now we have a seven.
Oh my gosh, he's scaring me.
Stop it!
Babies!
Oh.
Help me!
Please help me!
Oh my god!
Ah!
Is it because I didn't protect you?
I'm sorry.
My house is haunted.
I can talk to her.
I can't get the blood out!
It's a ghost maid!
No, it's a ghost nurse.
It's not a ghost maid.
Basement key!
Who keeps crying?
Do you remember?
21st night of park on, park on.
This is the basement, isn't it?
Oh, uh...
There's a...
Maybe going into the basement with my sanity so low is not a great idea.
I'm actually kind of freaked out.
Oh no!
Why do we need those?
Why do we need the shotgun shells?
Must be for later.
Why do we need this?
Save?
Oh yeah, let's save.
I did save after we beat the boss fight, but yeah.
What's this?
This safe is large and old-fashioned.
Made in the days...
My ceiling is leaking.
Made in the days when security was derived from the heavy metal construction, rather than secure locking mechanisms.
It doesn't look to be...
Oh, it doesn't look like it would be too difficult to break the combination.
If only Alex had a stethoscope to hear the tumblers more clearly.
Interesting, okay.
Our fuse box.
A fuse box and circuit breaker array is situated upon the wall.
All but one of the fuses are intact.
The absence of this one is suspicious.
And until it is replaced, the circuit connected to it is useless.
Oh!
Okay, we definitely want our house to burn down.
Alex jams the lucky penny in place of the missing fuse.
Oh, the place that we couldn't go into before!
It was too dark!
Why did all the sounds stop?
Okay, never mind.
I remember the, like, lever in here.
And everything.
What is...
Oh
boy, what is this?
What is all this?
A brass framework hangs from the ceiling, cradling the globe in the observatory above.
It seems to have been modified, now part of some elaborate locking mechanism.
Is this how we get into the underworld?
This must be it.
This must be...
Right?
It has to be.
It has to be!
Oh, I was gonna say...
Gosh, the game keeps out-timing me!
I was literally about to say, I'm going to raise my sanity unless we get something else other than baby crying.
And then we got a lady laughing!
Caprizona!
Welcome to my bishop bank!
I warned you.
My house!
What the?
Oh my god!
This can't be happening!
It took me a second to see I was sinking into the floor.
Uh, this room, right?
Oh gosh, last time we saw a bathtub, it was pretty freaky.
Journal of Maximilian Roivas!
That's not a page of the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
This is a page from Maximilian Roivas' journal.
It reads, I sought to love all, yet now love causes me pain and suffering.
I have learned to fear nothing, although it is nothing that I most fear.
All that were loyal to me now number amongst my worst enemies.
An antique medicine cabinet hangs on the wall.
Its wood stained from years of use in the ambient humidity of the room.
Should Alex open it?
Yes?
I also keep my pages in the bathroom.
We got a Legacy of Darkness!
You are not free to leave this plane until you complete a task for me.
You are to hunt and kill the master of this house.
Oh, no, no.
Do this one thing and you will be free.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Else fear the wrath of Xelaton.
Wait, are you coming inside?
No!
My safe spot!
Everything is complete for your arrival, master.
No!
Now it is time for the planets to align.
And that is not too many years from now.
Another Roivas has crossed our path.
This time, we will not be so merciful.
Mercy has no place in this world.
It has only a place for me.
He will meet such a horrible death that the rest of the line will never set foot in his house again.
Pray to me that they don't.
Pray to me anyway.
Yeah, pray to me anyway, guys.
Uh-oh.
So are there, like, dogs in my house now?
Are there dogs in my house?
Okay, I guess that's everything in here.
Okay.
Let's find out.
No!
Okay, I'll go out.
I just saved.
Golly.
The crying is just too much.
Please.
Oh my god!
Titties!
Do you remember Naomint?
The thrill of battle?
The clashing of bone in the 21st night of September?
Oh, what does it say?
A depiction of some monstrous landscape.
A blood-colored sky hangs over a dementedly surreal land in which flayed skin flaps in an acidic breeze.
What mind could have conceived this?
I'm gonna get demonetized.
I think.
Well, guys.
We have another page to read.
Which we shall do.
Or, another chapter, rather.
Which we shall do...
Next week?
Yes, next week?
Wait.
Yes.
Well, I guess then...
What?
In two weeks.
I have to figure out my schedule from when I'm back.
Right after this I'll post the schedule for this week.
Though it really is just a stream tomorrow.
And that's about it.
Thank you guys for joining me for more Eternal Darkness today!
We're really unlocking our Paragon power.
I felt so powerful after that last fight.
Thank you for playing!
Thank you guys for watching!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I'm starving.
That is one thing I am.
I think the food that my neighbors are making is coming in through the vents.
And it's making me so hungry.
So!
I'm going to go and eat.
I do have leftover pizza.
That's exactly what I was thinking.
Where can I go for the merch?
Yeah!
Lights.com!
You can pre-order my first ever Minto merch.
It's a Hoppy coat.
Great job on the boss!
Can't wait to see how this ends.
I also pre-ordered the Hoppy.
Thanks very much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I already ordered mine.
Thank you guys so much!
If you pre-ordered it.
Thank you!
I really, really appreciate it!
Oh my gosh, wait.
There we go.
Thank you!
Bye Hoppy!
Get Hoppy!
Be happy for Minto!
Yes.
I'll pre-order it soon.
Yeah!
No rush.
Thanks for the stream, Minto!
I was gaming today.
Yeah!
We gamed.
I said I was only going to do one chapter and so we did two!
Hoppy, Hoppy!
Hoppy, Hoppy, Hoppy!
Is that still a thing anymore?
Does anyone still care about the Neko meme?
Hoppy, Hoppy, Hoppy!
But, yeah.
Paragon, Paragon, Paragon!
Link for the merch!
Oh, let me do that.
Let me grab that.
Let me, hold on.
I have to resize my monitor.
Sorry, I just saw what Matara posted.
Girl, which one is a muffin?
Which one is a puppy?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Minto, Phantom.
Pre-order.
Hoppy.
Here.
Oh.
I did it.
Whoops.
Ah!
Wait!
Oh my gosh.
I think I just...
Oh no!
I just put someone in timeout!
Rob!
I'm so sorry!
I undid it.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry, Rob.
I undid it though.
I think you should be safe.
Oh, I see you.
She hates me.
No, Rob!
You're still here.
You're still with us.
I did save.
So, I'm going to end here.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
See you guys tomorrow if I see you.
Tomorrow, if you're curious what it's going to be, I'm just going to be doing some silly stuff in VRChat.
So, I'm just going to go around VRChat Explorer and, you know, do whatever.
Just going to be for funsies.
Yeah.
Since I have all my stuff set up.
For stuff that I was working on for my birthday.
What?
Oh, hint?
Hint?
Okie dokie!
Otsuminto!
Thank you guys again for watching.
I really, really appreciate it.
And I hope you guys have a great rest of your day or night, whenever, whatever.
Otsuminto, otsuminto!
Bye bye!
See you, see you, see you!
See you later!
Bye bye!
Thank you!